okay as chair of the health ways and
means committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor
as a result of the covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with the house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this is a public party this public body
is authorized to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the ways and means committee
executive sessions on pending
legislation may be held
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public
to observe and listen contemporariously
to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during the meeting
to the zoom electronic meeting platform
and the public has
access access to contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available to the house
calendar and the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
this the notice of this meeting complies
the house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting can call 271 3600
or email
hcs at lake.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us general four
and mr and the committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote
let's stop the meeting by taking roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law thank you
okay representative bernstein you can do
the roll call
thank you mr chair good morning to you
and good morning to everyone it's nice
to see everyone again
today is april 27 2021
it's currently 9 37 a.m we'll begin roll
call with representative patrick abrami
you're my home in stratham i'm i'm here
alone thank you representative mary
griffin
representative jordan owerry i'm here
the wife is in the house
good morning representative ober you're
in hudson with the usual six felines
from salem representative fred ducette
good morning in my home office in sale i
do have uh somebody working on another
part of the house
your clerk is alan versty and i'm at my
home office in beautiful nottingham new
hampshire
representative elliott here in salem new
hampshire at my daughter's house
she's in the house somewhere
representative jeanigan
i am at my house in salem and my wife is
somewhere in the house
representative hershel nunes
representative baxter thank you mr clerk
i apologize that my camera isn't working
i'm not sure why
but i'm in florida on vacation but still
ready for committee
um i'm alone right now but there may be
people coming through just so you know
well good morning and when your camera
is working we all want to see some tan
lines okay
representative spillsbury good morning
home alone in charlestown
representative tudor home in northwood
new hampshire
wife and grandkids are upstairs
representative army
i'm in lebanon alone thanks
representative ames
yes i'm here and jeffrey alone in my
home office
and representative southworth how are
things in dover this morning
great i'm here in dover alone
representative malloy
uh here uh greenland alone
representative thomas schamberg i am
president
uh representative bernstein in my home
my wife's in her office
good morning representative tucker i'm
here in randolph
uh alone from swansea representative
gomarlo
i am here in sunny swansea alone
right now but my husband wanders around
in and out
so representative laughman
representative
representative gorg good morning i am
present and alone
representative hacken phillips
coming to you from my office in concord
representative james murphy
good morning i am in my office alone in
hanover
our esteemed chair representative norman
major
good morning i'm in my home in plasto
and my wife is in the house mr chair
there are 21 members present
three are absent thank you
representative bernstein
the first public hearing
is for senate bill 139-fn
an act relative to bingo dates
and the
so there's a prime sponsor let me see
senator abard i just promoted
her uh her replacement
is her replacement her name is i
don't know hi it's trisha malillo for
senator avard
hey i assume you're going to introduce
house
senate bill 139-5 yes sir
okay the floor is all yours okay thank
you
good morning mr chair and members of the
house ways and means
committee my name is trisha molillo i am
the legislative aide for senator kevin
avard here to introduce senate bill 139
this bill 139 fn excuse me
this bill increases the number of game
dates allowed for bingo games per month
from 10
to 16 a month and 192 games
um a year and um that
is basically the bill i probably cannot
answer any questions for you
um senator evart had a conflict this
morning
and also i'm sorry senator rosenwald is
a co-sponsor on this bill um
she did not get um it was printed before
they got her name on it
all right and senator rosewall
available uh she is not available this
morning
okay all right
is that it yes thank you
okay well thank you for your testimony
thank you
and you you're not going to take any
questions right
no no sir sorry
on the sign up sheet there was only one
person
signed up a member of the public
in opposition and is not testifying
does anybody else have anything to say
on senate bill
139 we have an attendee with his hand up
michael mclaughlin and paul laflamme
also
okay would you like okay
i'm going to allow them to talk yes
michael first
good morning mr chairman and members of
the community my name is mike mclaughlin
i
apologize for not signing earlier uh and
i represent
community bingo in manchester and arrow
international which is a bingo
products manufacturer the only concern
we have relative to the bill is for many
many years
we've had the limit of 10 games per
month which has
created a a paradigm where a commercial
gaming hall
bingo hall in new hampshire of which
there are 15 of them
can provide services to at least three
charities per month
that's about 30 days and 120 per a year
this bill right now is is is some
unintended consequences by pushing up to
16 opportunities per month for a bingo
event
where we see the issue that a commercial
hall could then literally
only operate with two charities for the
32 days or the 30 days of the month
where the net unintended result would be
the elimination of certain charities in
commercial halls
i recognize there's uh an opportunity
for
seoul charities who see open dates and
open opportunities
to have additional dates but i we also
wanted to make the committee aware
that there is the possibility that by
increasing the
per charity day per month a commercial
hall
who is interested in you know
efficiencies of operation can say to a
lower performing charity
uh we're only going to use two charities
for our hall
interestingly the charitable bingo halls
collect revenue on a
foot traffic paradigm meaning more
people show up at five dollars or
seven dollars a night that's where they
get the revenue charities perform at
different levels in commercial halls
charities uh really that have the
carryover coverall bingo games drawing
the most people
so a commercial bingo hall's best
interest would be to
service charities who bring them more
foot traffic
so it there are issues on both sides and
mr pham will tell his issues but i
wanted to commit to be aware that the
uh 10 events per month
as it exists today is more beneficial to
more charities across the state thank
you very much mclaughlin uh
two questions are you a lobbyist yes i
say
i did sign in this morning on the uh and
sent some testimony late that's why i
apologize i'm a lobbyist for arrow
international
and community bingo and the record i
think will show when you pull it up that
i did
put it in this morning a little late but
i apologize for that
and the other question is are you in
support or
opposition opposition okay
thank you questions from the committee
uh
representative alvey followed by
representative romney
thank you mr chairman i think i'm a
a little behind in what has happened to
regular bingo
in this state we don't hear about it
hardly at all anymore
um you're you're saying
that the main revenue is that the people
who want to play bingo
pay an entry fee
commercial bingo halls are by um
administrative rule their revenue comes
from the number of people
who go to the hall so when you open the
doors of the hall you have 100 people
the commercial bingo hall
their revenue source is the number of
persons attending
so this is now in the rules no this is
yes it's in the rules but it's
it's the only revenue that a bingo hall
a commercial bingo hall
is allowed to collect the charity gets
the ma the revenue from lucky sevens
and from their percentage of the um the
take on the bingo game
thank you very much representative
romney
dear um hi my carrier very well thank
you um
so i just want to understand is that
bingo bingo every time we come back to
bingo i get to
be re-educated uh we have the commercial
halls i know
even some charitable gaming locations
have bingo
uh but but this first you know
um the first
is bingo also occurring in in church
basement still
and uh and is this what this bill is
really trying to address
that and not the commercial locations uh
i would think so and i think that's the
uh
the dilemma you have to deal with in
that
um a commercial bingo hall there are
standalone bingos uh there are bingos
that uh
operate in commercial halls where there
may be open nights
uh if you have a lower performing
commercial hall
that helen has 20 nights a month filled
up
uh that charity in that area might say
why can't i have
nights 12 13 and 14 to enhance my
revenue
and that's a valid point but a high
performing commercial bingo hall may say
because of this bill i don't need
charities x and y that don't bring me
any people i'll take
charities a and b because they're
filling the hall every night
and one of the things that i think is
important to remember bingo
is not a standalone product it's like a
loss leader for lucky seven sales so
it's bingo lucky seven
in addition the main driver of
attendance at commercial bingo halls is
the carryover coverall games
which are played once a night and can
have jackpots from 50 to 60 to 70
thousand dollars
so a high performing charity that
creates a
large carryover coverall is going to
attract more foot traffic to the
commercial hall
but again this is i'm looking this is an
unintended consequence of
allowing every charity they have 16
um dates per month we had some
discussion in the senate about
uh individual charities being able to
petition the lottery and say hey
we've got open dates in our locale can
we have them
uh and i think that would be a better
opportunity than to
cut blanche give the 16
uh available dates to any charity that
wants to take them
a follow-up mr chair oh
so again mike i just want to understand
so i see that this
does impact the commercial halls but was
that the intent
to for this bill to really uh
cover the commercial halls no this
is this bill is not uh
was not put forth by the commercial
halls at all
we've had this bill in the past but this
this is not a bill
that uh the commercial i represent
supports so it is not
a an effort by a commercial hall
to excise any charities it just happened
to
pop up because there's a situation a
missile phenomenon show
explain that his particular charity is
denied the opportunities to have extra
dates this is
not a charitable hall initiative but if
the church down the street decides to
have bingo night
i i looked this up just this morning so
it looks like the license fee per day
for a non-commercial location is 25
a day to have a license to do bingo
so i'm assuming that that that still
exists that bingo could be played in
any location that's that you know pays
to
meet the criteria and pays the license
fee commercial halls play a license fee
of 250 a year
uh so so again i'm just trying to
understand
the intent to by which the senator was
here to understand that
i can reach out to the senator to
understand uh
was the intent to modify what the
charitable game
obviously he says i get no commercial
invoice
when he electronically scans it again
yeah
oh who was that so anyway
it looks like because it also increases
the
uh of games per
uh calendar month from 120 to 192.
so i i i'm just trying to divide out
commercial halls for all other bingo
that may be occurring um and i i'll i'll
i'll probably mr chair i'll probably
reach out to the prime sponsor to
understand
what the motivation was you have a good
question there
representative romney thank you
for the questions of mr mclaughlin
saying and uh mr chairman
uh representative tucker had her hand up
and i just put mine up there
okay sorry about that representative
tucker
i'm not a bingo aficionado really
but i didn't understand what uh the
testifier
said about some sort of game that
is a once a night with a big pot
i didn't understand the word that he
used
it's madame represented the
carryover coverall bingo yeah tell me
what that word is
carrie it sounds like carryover it's
well
each night if the bingo numbers
that are put forth are not all covered
meaning
all of the numbers of the beat
all the numbers on the card are not
covered the
money bet carries over to the next
bingo event of the carryover coverall
game
so the money builds up every night until
the
carry over is covered completely by one
player
there are certain prizes come along each
evening but you have to cover all the
numbers
in one session to win the prize so it
carries over from event to event to
event
and the jackpot grows and grows and
grows and if you look on a social media
site for a charity they'll be
advertising
that their carryover coverall game has a
jackpot now of thirty thousand or forty
thousand or twenty thousand and that
drives the bingo community to that hall
i see so i really didn't understand
thank you very much
uh representative
thank you i just wanted to make sure are
we going to have
the lottery talking to us about this
since we can't have any either of the
sponsors
attending
do we have anybody from lottery
representative major yes uh gregory
moore
is is an attendee now he he was on the
sign up sheet
and valerie king is here valerie
that's what we need is valerie she knows
it's best valerie does lottery
but we got to listen first to the the
two now
apparently in the audience spyro as i
know as i know right now
one of the one other attendee wanted to
speak
i guess more than that now
um well gregory moore had signed up on
the sheet
and then there's paul laflamme and has
his hand
and i just admitted valerie king
i only have one person that signed up on
my sheet
i have i actually have donna susie and
greg moore
but donna susie is not here this is one
of
oh i'm sorry i've got the wrong darn
bill
i pulled up the wrong one sorry okay
one instead of 139 let me grab that one
valerie is in there okay then what we're
going to do
we'll listen to paul laflamme
and then valerie okay let me
let him talk okay
hi mr chairman members of the community
thank you so much for allowing me to
speak i apologize for
not signing up ahead of time i didn't
realize there was an 8 30 time cut off
and
i was there at nine o'clock signing up
and and was unsuccessful so i
i really appreciate you um allowing me
the courtesy of speaking now
are you a lobbyist and are you opposed
or in favor sure um i am not a lobbyist
i am the executive director of the
spartans german bugle corps
i am also employed by symphony new
hampshire as a production manager
both those organizations operate bingo
down here in nashua and so i'm speaking
on behalf of those two organizations
as well as myself i can continue
all right thank you again um so the
spartans have been doing bingo since
uh as long as i can remember my
grandfather founded the organization
uh so i remember growing up and my
parents going off to
to work bingo and so we've been doing it
literally forever
um and this bill
comes uh as a request from me
and the spartans and symphony new
hampshire to both our senators down here
senator avard and rosenwald so
um i was very excited to have both of
them uh as co-sponsors of this bill
and the motivation uh on their part i
know that was a big concern of the
committee here
is uh very simple the spartans would
like to run more bingo
and um we think that um
the time has come to allow us to to do
that
um the the bill i know that a lot of a
lot of discussion has occurred this
morning
it really is as simple as we want to go
from 10 dates a month
to 16 dates a month now
why is that um here in nashua
for example at the nashua bingo hall
which is a commercial hall
we have been closed on wednesdays
for about a year now why we've been
closed on wednesdays for about a year
because we don't have any charities
interested in taking on the
responsibility of running
bingo
are you still there we can't hear you
anymore
mr leflam we don't hear you
okay shoot can you hear me now yes all
right i apologize for that
not sure what happened but there's two
types of charities ones that do the
great walk-a-thons and the galas and
they have a large number of volunteers
that work for a short period of time on
a project then there's smaller charities
like the spartans
who have a smaller group of passionate
volunteers who are willing to do
one night or two nights a week on a more
specific type of project
and that's what we do and we're good at
it um so we would like to
quite frankly we would like to operate
on wednesdays at the national bingo hall
the idea that there is this pent-up
demand for charities that want to take
on the huge
task of running a bingo and that there's
like this waiting list to get into a
commercial hall
is just a false narrative it's not true
um if you were a commercial operator
i'm going to just ask you guys to think
about this for a second would it benefit
you
to run a hall with two charities or
would it benefit you
to run a hall with seven charities
what if a charity went out of business
your
you want to put more charities in your
hall have your eggs in more baskets
but you also want to be open so if you
can't find charities to operate
wouldn't it be good to be able to use
your charities that you already have to
fill that need
the consequences of being closed on
wednesdays
the hall owner has not collected any
rent has not collected that five dollars
ahead that mr mclaughlin spoke about so
so he's losing that revenue
there is a owner of the kitchen the
concession service who has been closed
he's not seen
any revenue the kitchen staff has not
received
you know wages for this period of time
because we're closed
and of course the spartans or any other
charity that might go in there has not
received
any um any of their profits
uh and quite frankly the spartans could
have used them in these tough covid
times not to mention the state of new
hampshire
has not received any tax revenue now
yes i know there's been a mention of the
a night license fee as outlined in the
fiscal note
and that is true i would also point out
the state has not received the seven
percent
tax on the winner take alls and the
carryover coveralls
which on an average night for the
spartans and i'm sure
there are charities with different types
of averages but on
um if the spartans had been operating
for that one extra night the state would
have generated during this time
frame roughly fifteen thousand dollars
in extra revenue
for doing nothing other than allowing us
to operate
um the the fiscal note talks about the
twenty five dollar per game date
as a as a possible consequence of of
this bill
it does not talk about the seven percent
tax using the same
logic that the fiscal note uses
multiplying by 200
which i don't think any charity is going
to um you know
use the maximum number of dates but
that's an extra 3.4 million dollars just
using the spartans averagings
so um the state has has a as an
interest in allowing this bill to go
forward as well
um the bill is um like i said very
simple
um please don't try to confuse it with
with
foot traffic and carry over coveralls
and
the differences between the commercial
halls and in the church basement bingos
mr mclaughlin suggested there are 15
commercial halls
in the state uh multiply that by the
three charities required to
to run it that's 75 um
uh game dates the
uh the fiscal note talks about this 200
or i'm sorry 75 charities running in a
commercial bingo hall i meant to say
um the fiscal note talks about 200
charities running bingo at this time so
it's not the commercial halls are not
even half
of the bingo's running in the state so i
think that that's uh
it's a it's a herring that
is not even a consideration for this
bill
but other than that i'm happy to answer
questions um
i have been doing bingo for way too long
as
valerie king will testify to she would
be happy to get rid of me
um and um happy to answer any questions
thank you for your question uh
representative romney followed by
representative
thank you mr chair thank you mr lefleum
for your testimony
i just want to understand the key thing
i want to make sure is that we're not
going to be
boxing out any charities that uh
already have dates uh so
your testimony says that that's not
going to happen because
all the dates aren't taken but you're
saying it's only closed on a wednesday
so i'm trying to reconcile that if it's
only closed on a wednesday
i could see it being closed one
wednesday a week because
at the current roll maximum of 10 days
that's 30 days in our 31 day
month one day have to have to be closed
uh but it says no more than 10 days and
this would be no more than 16 days
here's my his my question really is who
controls the dates is it is
your like your facility in nashua that
you utilize
do they control the dates that they give
to different charities to do this
so we have a lease with the hall owner
that at least states that we
um can operate on certain dates and we
agree to that now you can't just take
them away without breaking the lease
the reason why there is a disconnect
between the number of dates
and and um that are allowed and the
closed on wednesdays in practice
charities typically pick
one day a week to run their game so like
the spartans do mondays and tuesdays
so and that has to do with um
lucky seven bonuses and you don't wanna
you don't wanna use your lucky seven
bonuses
that you develop over time on a monday
and then give them away to your
to uh somebody that might win it on a
wednesday
um the players get upset about that
because they feel that's their money et
cetera
um so so typically we do just
one day a week so obviously with 10 days
currently allowed
some months have five mondays and five
tuesdays
so i've maxed out other months might
have only
four mondays and five tuesdays so i only
get to do
nine dates that month just because of
the logistics
of the way a day of the week works
because there's only one wednesday in
the week obviously
um so this would allow a charity to do
um you know in my case a monday a
tuesday
and a wednesday there may be some weeks
where
or some months rather that we can't do
all
uh you might ask why is there 16 and not
well that's to to cover um
fluctuations in the calendar where you
might have
more more date more mondays more
tuesdays less mondays
more wednesdays etcetera okay
thank you thank you appreciate your
testimony absolutely
followed by representative schamberg
yeah i think i'm going to pass i'm
incredibly confused by
all of these um
yes thank you thank you for your
testimony can you answer the question
will church bingos be able to move up or
to 16 or do they have an unlimited
number
now they would be able to move up to 16
as well
so all the com unlike uh the poker rooms
where
um the the the poker room operator
um controls the games
and runs the games and there's also a
waiting list to get in
bingo is different the charities run the
games themselves a bonafide member needs
to be present
to run the games um
so
even in the this will be treated the
exact same in a commercial hall
as well as a church basement thank you
very much
any further questions saying none thank
you
janine would you let valerie came in
uh valerie's in and mike
michael um mclaughlin has a
has his hand up again no i don't
no you don't no
i just loaded it maybe i never lowered
it i'm sorry thank you i thought i had
okay valerie
good morning mr chairman and committee
members my name is valerie king with new
hampshire lottery
i'm here to answer any questions you
have i think paul did a great job
explaining it but i
i can answer any additional questions
you have
any questions for valerie
uh mom yeah representative romney i
couldn't find my
my hand button here so um
hi valerie how are you
uh so
[Music]
so just want to make sure we understand
so this this affects both
the the church charities as well as the
the
uh the halls is that correct
yes that's correct and
uh so it is different than terrible
gaming it sounds
like in terms of how did how the dates
are controlled is that correct
um just to clarify uh bingo is a
charitable game
i think you're referring to games of
chance um are
poker rooms and yes it's totally
different regulations totally different
set of uh rules and
number of dates allowed
right uh last question um
is is there a backlog of charities that
want to get involved or not
we're not aware of any waiting lists um
we don't maintain a waiting list but we
haven't
received any complaints i'm not aware of
any complaints of
charities not being able to play bingo
okay thank you
any further questions for
[Music]
mrs kim yes
um i do
personally thank you mr chairman
on do we
is there if there are very few uh
charities that
want to sponsor bingo is there
really a reason why we are limiting
then what is the reasoning for limiting
the number of days
at this point and i have another
question about the
the derivatives of the church basements
so i i can't speak to the uh original
intent of the
ten game dates per month maya some i
mean this this
the legislation goes back to when i was
in high school and probably before
which was a long time ago um but i i
would assume that it had to do with
bingo used to be a much more popular
game um so they probably did need to
limit it at that time
it has been a dying game there
it's it's shrinking in size the number
of
of charities willing to do it and
whatnot so
um i don't believe that there's a need
to put that cap
any longer
thank you and the other question
i've got is about
senior centers our senior center does
penny ante penny bingo actually
penny a card on how are
they regulated at this point
um depending upon how they actually run
their games they may be exempt
there are senior bingos that are exempt
they have to follow certain criteria but
they can
they are exempt thank you that would be
them
any further questions of mrs king
saying none do we have anybody else
janine not that i can see thank you
then i'm going to close the public
hearing on senate bill 139-fs
the next public hearing has to do with
senate bill
101-fn an act
increasing the minimum gross business
income required for filing a
business profits tax
and senator sosi
is the prime sponsor and
question i don't see senator soucy but
senator bradley has his hand raised
then uh well i don't really like senator
bradley
okay
senator bradley that's all yours
good morning mr chair i think i
had signed on for senate bill three but
since senator associates not here
i believe senate bill 101 is a bill that
lifts the threshold
on filing the business profits tax from
to 75 000 and as i recall
it passed the senate unanimously and we
commend it to you
and i just promoted uh senator soucy
my apologies okay senator susie
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i'm donna soucy
and i'm the prime sponsor of
senate bill 101 i represent senate
district 18 which is manchester's
wards 5 through 9 in the town of
litchfield
this bill is a bill to increase
the threshold for filing a business
profits tax return
the current threshold is gross business
income in excess
of fifty thousand dollars this bill
would raise that threshold
to gross business income in excess of
seventy five
thousand 000 and it would apply to the
taxable period beginning
after december 31st 2021
the bill would take effect on july 1st
of 2021.
um most importantly though i think the
committee should be aware
the current limit was set in 1993.
it has been 27 years and i believe
that we should be increasing the
threshold at the very least to keep up
with inflation
but i also think it's critical that we
look at these thresholds
particularly during these times because
the increase of the threshold would lift
a regulatory burden off
so many of our small businesses and sole
proprietorships
reduce administrative costs and also
reduce accounting fees for so many of
them
the department has included a fiscal
note as you can see it is based on some
data from 2018
but it does show that even using those
numbers thousands of ben
businesses would benefit from increasing
this threshold and i would
encourage the committee to vote ought to
pass
this was a bill that was unanimously
voted upon
in the senate last year uh it has been
unanimous again
this year so it certainly has bipartisan
support
and as i said i would encourage you to
vote out to pass would be happy to
answer any questions mr chairman
thank you senator um
any questions from the committee hold on
a second
representative yuri
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question senator susie
uh when the senate uh discussed this did
they discuss
raising it even higher because you
mentioned
uh keeping pace with inflation and i
don't disagree that
75 000 is a nice move but
why was not uh 100 125 or 150 considered
uh or did it even come up in the senate
discussions
thank you ma'am thank you representative
already um
the question of whether to raise it even
beyond
that did not come up um in the
conversation
uh i think it certainly if you were to
raise it
beyond the 75 would once again encompass
many more businesses therefore it may
have an additional cost associated with
it
but the question of a hundred thousand
or 125 was not debated
um in the senate ways and means
committee
any further questions um
yes yes represent yes mr chair
you have a fall follow up please yes
uh senator susie do you think your uh
your committee or the senate as a whole
would be adverse to raising the 75 to
uh talking with several uh accounting
firms and they
they think that uh uh an even higher uh
filing limit would be advantageous based
upon the amount of taxes
or paperwork that they file that for no
benefit
because no taxes are due would that be
considered
uh representative thanks again for the
question uh personally
uh yes i would be open to that
consideration
would of course want to consult with the
department
to determine the impact but i think
that's
a possibility that would be entertained
thank you senator susie
any further questions seeing none
then next signed up to speak
and support is greg moore the lobbyist
from the american for prosperity in new
hampshire
greg moore
be there shortly
hi there can you hear me
excellent sorry a little technical
issues when they when it jumped over to
me
uh yes uh mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to speak here today my name is greg
moore i'm the state director with
americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire
and we fully support senate bill 101
believe it's good policy
as a fiscal note demonstrates uh over 86
percent of the businesses that filed
that fell
into this range had a tax liability of
zero
meaning that uh that's over four
thousand different
uh entities had to go and get their
taxes prepared
but had no tax liability which obviously
creates a deadweight cost for each of
those small businesses
and beyond that as uh as
senator susie pointed out this uh this
uh current limit of fifty thousand
dollars has been in place since 1993.
i did a check and based
on data from the bureau of labor
statistics
the consumer price index has increased
by 83
so this 50 percent increase is
beneficial certainly uh and would
certainly help a lot of small businesses
as well as as well as reduce some of the
administrative burden not at the
department level
it still doesn't quite keep up with
inflation i think that that uh
one prospect that we might ask the
committee to consider is something
similar to what we did in uh house bill
1418 back in 2012
where in addition to raising the
threshold
what we did for the bet we also indexed
it for inflation
so uh i would ask the committee that we
fully support the bill as it stands
uh we would fully support the bill at a
higher level uh but we
think that maybe adding an an inflation
index to it
going forward similar to what we did
with uh with the bet
would be a positive step uh i will say
that that uh this legislation was
uh as senator susie mentioned was
initially filed
back in 2018 and it was filed at the
hundred thousand dollar level
not the not the seventy five thousand
dollar level and the senate
upon passing it in a senate ways it
means we scaled it back from a hundred
thousand two seventy five thousand
uh so maybe uh if you get a chance to
talk to one of your colleagues
uh over at the senate ways and means who
is serving in the last term they might
be
able to offer you some ideas or guidance
as to why they
they in fact scale it back from a
hundred thousand to seventy five
thousand
so with that i'd be happy to take any
questions from the committee
representing your league
thank you mr chair um mr moore what was
that uh uh bill that you uh
referenced with the uh inflation index
attached please
sure it was house bill 1418 from 2012
the 2012
session uh which uh obviously
serving as the house chief of staff at
the time i was taking a keen interest in
um and that was a bill that not only
raised the limit
for raise a limit on the bet for filing
threshold but also
index it for inflation uh thank you mr
moore
any further questions of mr moore
representative elmi
this is not a question because i
am a sponsored co-sponsor but on i
thought i'd just like to testify briefly
go ahead representative thank
you thank you thank you here you have uh
alan may have a
are we dismissing the the are we
dismissing the uh
uh mr moore well
he's testifying as a new justifying
person
mr morgan like representative uh
bursting has a question of the prior
speaker
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair uh
good morning mr moore nice to see your
name at least
as not your face um
anyway you get that reaction a lot
you had testified that over 86 of the
businesses that filed within the range
of 50 000 to 75 000 first revenue had
zero tax liability
do you have numbers on if it if that
threshold were
increased to a hundred thousand uh
what percentage of businesses would
still have a zero liability
i don't i i i suspect what i would do is
go back and look at the
the initial fiscal note uh from the
legislation that was introduced in 2018.
i believe it was senator ditch who
was the prime sponsor of that
legislation uh
what i might refer you to go back and
and review maybe that fiscal note that
might
might offer a substantial amount of
guidance good idea thank you very much
thank you any further questions for
mr moore i don't see any
soul representation thank you mr
chairman
uh representative elmi uh city of
lebanon
on i and you were in
in and i think representative hollery
were
also on the committee in 12
2012. and uh
i wanted to talk about the indexing
which is something that i had suggested
when that bill came through
on we had a situation where we'd had 100
inflation i think at that point since
the time that that one had been
been done and um there was a bill
brought
in to increase the threshold by that
amount
and i thought wow that's a lot and i
went back and i can't i
calculated it there had been a lot more
inflation that
that decade and um
it was on it was just it was just a
little bit below 100
at that point for um
since the bt threshold had been
established
and on it did cost us a fair amount of
money to do that
at that point in the revenues so um i
suggested and everybody else thought it
was a good idea that we
index on that threshold
so that we would not get sudden
changes in our revenues due to
to changing the threshold as we went
and on i was
i forget whether i was on the bill or
not last night
last term but on
it did uh get considered in the senate
and i was following it
and they did um
they did look at the number of people
that would be exempted by
changing it up to a hundred and decide
that that
that and the amount of money involved
was
too much for the budget at that point
and um take it down to 75
and i don't have the precise numbers
here but the dra would have them
and they could do a recalculation as
well
of of how many people get exempted i
believe one of the problems
is that if you exempt up to a high
enough level
you encourage people to fudge
fudge their books you don't catch the
people that should be paying
but i'm not sure about that
thanks any questions for representative
representative major there's a hand
raised in the attendees
uh henry ville i'm not sure if i
pronounced it correctly
um first of all
any any questions for representing all
me
i don't say any so we'll let henry
come in um
and he just lowered his hand so never
mind i guess
sorry i just wish to testify
for or against senate bill
101. the sign up sheet that i have here
there's
16 that signed up in support five
and to oppose it and one neutral
and i believe everybody has a copy of
the
fiscal note quick guide which
does that the bill as is would
cost the state of approximately one and
a half million dollars
does the dra want to say anything
carolyn just raised her hand i'll
promote her thank you
carolyn as all yours do you have
anything to say on
senate bill 101 or
when people suggest that maybe you wrote
a hundred thousand
thousand or use the indexing
representatives this is carolyn lehrer
assistant commissioner at the department
of revenue
um i we don't have any testimony to
offer you today about this bill
but i'm happy to answer any questions
representative major as the screen
was refreshing as i was promoted i think
i caught the end of your question
which was relative to whether we had a
recommendation
um with respect to either the hundred
thousand or
the indexing we certainly don't have a
recommendation but those are
both um changes that we could administer
here at the department
um if you do desire to go either
with a higher threshold or with indexing
do you have any idea
what the penalty would be going from
75 to 100 where
cost that revenue about one and a half
million dollars
at the 75 000 level but it might be
that's a hundred thousand so i we don't
have an
updated analysis for that but i do have
in front of me the analysis that we did
for senator um then senator diege's
bill in 2019 which used
2016 data and we estimated the fiscal
impact of going to a hundred thousand at
about 2.2 million but we could certainly
update that analysis
um with 2018 data so that you could
compare it to the
uh the fiscal note that you have for
senate bill 101
i think that would be helpful sure
any questions for the dra
carol mayor
representative tucker
you muted uh representative tucker
sorry i wonder whether when you do the
analysis of the difference between
seventy five thousand
and a hundred thousand you could choose
a point
in the middle so that if there's some
desire to compromise we would know
what the effect was of that compromise
point
eighty five thousand ninety thousand
but i can just envision are you really
would have the number but it wouldn't be
available
while you're doing the analysis could
you
come up with a in between point and know
the effect of that
we can do that we'll we'll do 85 unless
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman um
i was just wondering how difficult would
it be to administer
and indexed you know if we did go to an
indexed situation
i'm i'm thinking that do you think it
would cause a lot more
errors on people that were potentially
using last year's
um you know i know a lot of times when i
i use
i do my taxes i look at last year's as
kind of a guide not that i
trust every i look to see what's changed
but i would imagine others do that as
well do you do you think that we'd have
a lot more
people making errors by not just having
a set
number as opposed to indexing
thank you for the question
representative we already indexed the
bet
threshold every two years um so i think
to the
i don't think there would be any
additional errors if we matched the bpt
um i don't have an answer for you as to
whether the
the changing threshold for the bet every
two years is currently
causing errors although i suspect
um that given technology
and the um the companies that produce
electronically submitted
returns that for the most part it
is automated for taxpayers meaning
they don't have to look it up at all the
form is programmed
to have the correct threshold
okay thank you any further questions for
mrs lear the ra representative rodney
uh thank you mr chair uh thank you uh
miss lair um
thank you for reminding us that the
index is every two years for the uh
bet so if we were to do this would it be
easier for you to manage if we did the
same
instead of making it every year make it
every other year uh
in the same in sync with the uh b-e-t
melissa can jump in because she act if
she would like to because she actually
does
the calculation um if she disagrees but
i think the easiest thing for us would
be
to simply match the schedule that we
currently
have for the bet which is updating
every two years we would simply do them
both at the same time
okay thank you
i just promoted melissa
yes good morning members of the
committee melissa rollins department of
revenue
um i was rejoining so i didn't fully
hear
carolyn's answer on us um being promoted
but i'm thinking i'm saying the exact
same thing as her i don't think it would
be
an issue um i think it's much easier if
we do do it in sync with the bpt
just because um you're not changing
thresholds on different you're
changing them all at the same time
probably easier for taxpayers
and easier for us as well to make sure
that those are
in sync and updated at the same time
every other year
thank you melissa
are you all set representative romney
thank you
any further questions ask of the dra
saying nothing does anybody else
want to testify for or against senate
bill 101.
no raise hands then i'm closing the
public hearing on senate bill 101
take a quick five-minute break before we
go to the next public hearing
on senate bill three so a five minute
break
so
foreign
okay
i think we have just about about
everybody back
the recording started again
uh you're muted representative
i'm sorry it doesn't we don't stop it
during breaks
and i just promoted request i mean uh
senator bradley
okay good then i'm going to open the
public hearing
on senate bill 3-fn
an act clarifying the tax treatment of
federal
paycheck protection program loans
the prime sponsor is senator bradley
senator bradley it's yours to introduce
the bill
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee
pleasure to be before you today for the
record jeb bradley
from wolfeboro the senate
passed this bill about a month ago on a
bipartisan vote
of 23-0 with one member
not participating due to a conflict of
interest
the purpose of the bill is to clarify
new hampshire law
and to make it consistent with federal
statute that the payroll protection
program was not deemed to be a taxable
event the federal government has
adopted that policy that it's not a
taxable event
and i believe and the senate concurs
with that
that new hampshire should not make this
a taxable event either
payroll protection was designed and
it did a good job quite frankly of
keeping the economy afloat
during the pandemic when our state and
our nation face significant
economic uncertainty
as you recall new hampshire's
unemployment rate skyrocketed to above
15 percent
thankfully we are back at 3 percent now
and i think a
large measure of that was the impact of
the payroll protection program
businesses could keep people on their
payroll
and not overburden our unemployment but
also
it allowed the payment of mortgage
interest it kept loans
performing rent was able to be paid by
businesses
utilities all of this helped prop up the
economy
let's remember mr chairman who
did the payroll protection program
primarily benefit well it was targeted
to companies of 500 and fewer employees
so the largest businesses around our
country and in new hampshire
were never eligible and they are some of
the largest business profits tax
taxpayers in terms of their overall
business profits
tax receipts senate bill 3 does not
affect them
and given the strong business tax
revenue i think that
we would probably all agree that these
companies
for the most part seem to be performing
fairly well
our business tax revenue is
significantly ahead
in fiscal 21. i also think you can't
just look at the businesses that the
payroll protection program helped
you have to look at the thousands and
thousands of jobs
of hard-working men and women across our
state
who are better able to withstand the
impact of the pandemic and the economic
ravages
congress has made it clear that the
payroll protection plan was never
intended as i said before
to be taxable and i think new hampshire
should
also make it clear that the payroll
protection program
is meant to protect businesses and
employees
not to become the payroll taxation
program
in new hampshire the issue is
we are tied to the 2018 irs
code not the 2020 code and so
that's why the department of revenue has
determined
based on the fact that we are tied to
the 2018 code
that it is a taxable event so that's
why we need senate bill 3.
we also have to look at what's happening
around
the rest of the country there are 35
states that clearly
do not tax the payroll protection plans
there are four other
states that either don't allow it to
begin with or
it is mostly not taxed and so there are
states only in new england vermont
along with new hampshire has deemed that
it's
taxable and i think it's
vitally important not only to protect
the businesses
that had to withstand the ravages of the
pandemic
but also the message that it sends
to businesses that are contemplating
locating in new hampshire
expanding in new hampshire staying in
new hampshire
we have done a lot over the last five or
six years to make
new hampshire more competitive lower
workers compensation rates
lower business taxation rates we've
tried to address and i think we are
making progress on things like
affordable housing that make it possible
to
attract employees into new hampshire
the last thing that we want to do is
send a message
in the live free or die state that while
washington has determined
it's not a taxable event that we on the
other hand
will make it a taxable event so
i believe that for all of the reasons
above that's why
um we had a 23 to zero vote
totally bipartisan obviously on
quite frankly what's a very big issue in
the state of new hampshire and one that
could engender
controversy but senators came together
across the spectrum to say
we need to make sure that we protect
new hampshire businesses so thank you
very much
uh mr chairman i would uh
happy to answer any questions good um
first it would be representative
schamberg followed by
representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
senator uh representative schamberg here
i'm having just a little hard time
understanding if senate bill 3 passes
ppa loans will not be included in the bp
tax base that i understand
so why should business expenses paid for
with pp
loans loan amounts remain
deductible when they filed taxes
can you um i mean business expenses
has always been deductible the fact is
that when congress authorized the
payroll protection plan as part of the
cares act
it was never determined to be a taxable
event
in washington so because
as i explained our code is tied to the
irs code not the 2020 code
that's what makes it a taxable event and
and if we want to
a hurt you know businesses with
a very significant tax and remember it's
the 500
or fewer employee businesses not the
largest businesses but
quite frankly the main street businesses
i think not only would we be hurting the
lifeblood of the new hampshire economy
but we'd also be sending a message
that new hampshire is undermining its
competitiveness on a national scale
and as we're trying to recover from the
pandemic that's not a good
uh good message to send to
businesses in our state and around the
country
thank you representative ames
okay i'm i got there i got it unmuted
uh senator bradley good morning and
thank you for
putting forward this much needed bill
um essentially
i have an a related question to the bill
it's closely related
uh essentially this bill conforms
new hampshire's approach to the federal
approach
the federal government has taken the
lead on this they've created
the ppp loan program and as a part
and i'd say an integral part of that
program
they've they've established the exempt
exemption for the forgiven loans and the
expenses that go along with that
and uh that's the way it is for a not
a state that doesn't conform
automatically like new hampshire
and we're in a minority i think
nationwide on that score
it requires an affirmative decision and
that's what
sp3 is asking us to do
the the question that i
get to is whether well
one other context point is that the cost
of doing this
seems to be rising almost as we speak
through the estimating process the dra
estimate
that came out the revised fiscal note
has put it at 91 million dollars i think
um and i i have questions perhaps
many of us do about that estimate but
that's
putting that aside it's significant
money the
question that i get to is
the grant money that's coming to us from
the federal government through
arpa which is significant
maybe 900 million dollars or so and
there's a tax cuts provision
in arpa that
is a limiting factor for states if they
cut taxes then
uh pouring money federal harper money in
to fill the hole
is something that in some way
is forbidden and what that way is is
being explored by treasury
as we speak but
treasury has just issued a guidance
maybe two weeks ago
that tells us that this provision
is going to be different where a state
chooses
to conform this is my understanding
conform to the arpa
not harper the ppp approach to
tax exemption in other words to update
its irc code
effectively cutting taxes for at the
state level for our firms
that have received ppe loans
that that's okay that doesn't trigger
the tax cuts provision
and my question to you is whether you've
had occasion to look at this question
and
whether my understanding is correct
essentially that if new hampshire
chooses to
take some of that pp that arka money
and steer it to fill the hole created
whatever that hole is created by
conformity
that that would be okay to do
and it'll be a choice that new hampshire
could make without worrying about
being penalized for doing it
so let me just um thank you very much uh
representative ames
um i would just say a couple of things
in looking at the fiscal estimate
it has changed um a couple of times the
first
fiscal note had a range of 80 million to
135 million
um a subsequent fiscal note i believe
had a
low range of 65 million and now
the most recent fiscal note um
discussed 90 million dollars so i think
it is very difficult as i'm sure
dra will testify to the exact um
you know magnitude of what might happen
if we pass senate bill three
but let me just say again it's a tax
increase if we pass senate bill three
and i
i i judge from your question you agree
with that and agree with
um the fact that um you know we should
not be doing it
now i i'm like you and i think everybody
else
in new hampshire waiting for that final
treasury guidance
on the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill that the president
recently signed
and congress enacted um i i think it's
safe to say and i i'd take a slightly
different approach
if we're the 40th state at a minimum
to say we're not going to tax um
the payroll protection plan proceeds
i can't see any way that
the federal government would trigger the
provision that was put in
the recent stimulus bill
um and and override that i think with 40
states
if new hampshire becomes the 40th state
that debate is um long over in terms of
uh what the treasury guidance will say
in
in terms of other you know taxation
issues
i think we'll have to see what happens
okay follow-up follow-up
and just really to essentially agree
with
senator bradley on this um i think that
uh that by my reading of
the statement put out by treasury they
have jumped the gun on this particular
provision
probably for the very reason that you've
just set out
that some 30 40 states have already
uh essentially conformed either
automatically or by choice
and it would make no sense to
say oops you know you're gonna you're
gonna pay a penalty under
the money for doing that it just doesn't
make sense and so they've
i believe they've made it clear maybe
somebody some people will disagree in
their interpretation of that statement
but
so we're going down that road and then
there's the remaining question here in
the state of what to do with that harp
of money and
uh and maybe it would be to fill
um to use part of it to fill this hole
and i'm open to that i i trust uh
you would be uh yeah obviously i think
again um you know businesses
that have survived the pandemics um
now's not the time to
you know switch gears on them and say
the federal government has said it's not
a taxable event but in the live free or
die state
we think it is i think um
you know we need to make sure that we've
done everything to
help businesses get through this and
continue to get through it i think
senate bill 3
does that and i thank you for your
support of it
thank you mr chair uh thank you senator
bradley
um so yes the the latest fiscal note is
uh
91.7 uh million
uh from the dra but then we got some
guidance this morning that
because uh they said that uh
of the what's remaining in the second
draw
which was passed in december and ends on
may 31st
uh was 290 billion potential loans
and i guess already 240 billion have
already been awarded so
but only 50 billion so
uh that could be awarded so that that
91.7
midpoint i would assume of the dras
estimate
wouldn't go up a bit but not that much
so with that said uh and yes
you mentioned senator that uh we're
all amazed at the revenues that have
come in so far this year
uh and uh is it
is your position and giving being
majority leader that
uh even if even if this number was uh
called say 110
million or 120 million uh
that that's something that we can manage
if we
get past this bill i i mean yes it is
and thank you for the question i think
you know in looking at the first fiscal
note the upper range of 135 million we
felt it was manageable then
too so um what it ends up being i think
we're probably not going to know
for some time but it's
i believe not only important i think i
keep stressing this that
um we do everything possible to help
you know the businesses that need the
help in surviving the pandemic but
also the statement that it makes in
terms of new hampshire being
open for business and and welcoming
business i think
that's vital too if if we don't pass
this
what opportunities are we going to lose
as a state
i i remain very concerned about that
also
thank you senator representative
spielsberg
thank you very much mr chairman and
thank you senator bradley
uh it's obvious that you and the senate
have put a lot of effort into this
and uh feel committed but there there is
something that's really perplexing me
the ppp was structured as a loan program
and it stipulated certain um
qualifying expenses
that would allow for excusing the debt
so for it to be converted from a loan
um you know to essentially a grant
with the debt excused you had to
use it for qualified expenses at least
60 percent of which were
payroll and as as you say
the real intended beneficiary
was the employees the country of denmark
for example
did essentially the same thing but
bypassed local government and
employers and just sent the money to the
employees
same outcome so here's what's confusing
me
if all of the money received from ppp
had to be offset by qualified deductions
why is there actually any
business tax liability for those
businesses to be concerned about
or to put it a different way
isn't it really the case that these
businesses
would get a benefit from sb3 and
conversely the state
would take a hit in their tax revenues
only to the extent
that the exact same deductible expenses
that were paid with ppp funds now
are allowed to be used to offset
revenues already or otherwise generate
um am i missing something so
i'm not a tax expert i'm not an
accountant i'm not a lawyer
um so just understand that when i try to
answer the question
my understanding of when the cares act
passed and how it was structured
is that payroll had to account i believe
it was for 70 or 75 percent of the
eligible expenses and it was limited to
beyond that certain things like the
payment of mortgage
utility and rent so it was a fairly
limited
amount of items that could be expensed
by a business
under a ppp loan it did its job
in the sense that
our state you know shot
our unemployment rate shot up over 15
it's back to three percent now
and um businesses are having a hard time
finding work
at this point in time so
i think it it did its job and now it's
at least in my view not the time to say
okay
you got through this this grant helped
you and remember you have to
in order to um get it
turned into a grant it has to be
signed off on by the banker that
originated the ppp loan so you have to
have abided by you know the stipulations
that i outlined previously
um that turns it into a grant
i it was never intended to be a taxable
event
in washington for good reason it was
intended to keep the economy afloat i
i don't i think new hampshire should
treat it the same way it's
it should be a treated as a grant not a
taxable event
mr chairman have a brief follow-up
thank you i understand
your intention to provide the maximum
amount of assistance
to businesses were placed in a difficult
situation because of government
decisions
uh but i just wonder if it
if we can agree that effectively what we
would be doing if we
passed sb3 is we would be
adding an additional
form of assistance by relieving our
businesses
uh to the tune of about another 91
million dollars in taxes they would have
owed
on income otherwise earned
i guess i don't see it that way
representative
because i think in most instances for
those smaller businesses
500 and fewer employees they got payroll
protection
it replaced revenue that they would have
lost
as a result of the pandemic so i i don't
the way i look at it we're not giving
an additional benefit there's not a
double counting here
it kept businesses afloat that was its
intent
and it performed now is not the time to
backtrack and um say oh by the way
unlike the federal government which has
said it's a grant if you abide by the
conditions
we're going to make it a payroll
taxation
event i i just don't see it that way
thank you senator representative
thank you mr chairman uh
senator bradley i i've got on two
questions here one of them
is the timing on this on
we got this guidance from the u.s
treasury already but it's sufficiently
vague that
some people including dra are not sure
that it means that we can use money from
arpa to pay for this
um well while they're following that
up on
our if it turns out that
we're on our own for paying for this is
this going to be
something accounted for in the senate
budget
which it was not accounted for in the
house because we did not have this bill
yet
so it's a fairly substantial amount of
money
any way they measure it yeah my and
i am not a member of the senate finance
committee my understanding is that
um it will be accounted for
thank you and could i add something else
we've been talking about on
putting a preamble onto this that
would on assuming that the arbor money
is available
on point point out that
on this uh would be able to be
paid for from the the federal funds but
uh would would be considered within
uh all the other things that the federal
funds might be spent for by the state
uh the wording obviously is not very
clear yet
um well thank you very much uh
representative all me i would ask
that um if you're going to
put a preamble on that you know we work
together and make sure that
any changes to the language don't
undermine the intent
of the language um as i said before
uh and i think that you know if you
um trying to find where the map that
somebody provided
to me came from but just looking at the
map of the 39 states
that right now do not tax the ppp
loans i see almost
no way having been in washington before
that suddenly the
new administration or congress is going
to reverse
course on the ppp loans with if new
hampshire
joins in not taxing it'll be 40 states
and there may well be
some of the remaining 10 that are in the
same
process that we're at now in
consideration senate bill 3.
so i just don't see it as a
threat that we need to worry about
given the vast majority of states
already
are not taxing it because of the way
their tax structure works with
conformity
hello mr chair
thank you on yes i i understand we ought
to
the committee ought to work together
with you uh about any wording
if we do this but the um
the idea was if it is uh
refundable essentially by by arpa on
that would take about a ninth out of
the arpa monies that we get and
uh i would hope that a lot of that is
going to be going to broadband
and roads and bridges and other things
that are really
important to the uh future of our
economy
in this state so it it is
a decision that we all are going to have
to
look at eventually in terms of
how the arpa money gets spent assuming
the legislature has a say in that this
time
and um that's was
the reason we were thinking of a
preamble so everybody would have that in
mind thank you
and i i appreciate that again and i
guess that
um i would ask you to support my bill
senate bill 85
which creates a matching grant
initiative
um for broadband expansion and obviously
the ability to use some of that money
but again let me let me stress it was
never
intended in new hampshire and it was
certainly never
intended federally to be a taxable event
this
this money um propped up the economy
and kept businesses and hardworking men
and women
afloat it it should not be treated as a
taxable event
and and again you've got the
impact that it would have on the current
businesses
in new hampshire but i think just as big
as that
is the message that it sends that oh
we're now in the taxation um raising
business and
and i think as we're trying to
distinguish ourselves as a state that's
open for business and we want to recover
from the pandemic
that message would be very destructive
further questions if not i do have a
question
representative
the patient check protection program
has helped out a lot of a lot of our
businesses
and essentially what says that if they
used it for what was intended for
then the loan is
turned into a grant and in addition to
that
they can have a they can deduct all the
expenses
so they get a double benefit of this
now especially on the first part
of the first stimulus there were a
number of companies
that applied for this but they weren't
qualified they were in desperate need of
help
but they weren't qualified primarily on
the first one because
they started their businesses in 2019
and in 2020 they made more so that
automatically disqualified them what
would you do
to help those businesses some of them
had to go out of business
and someone had to mortgage their homes
and everything else what would you do
to help those businesses that didn't
qualify for the ppp
that really needed it uh well thank you
very much
um mr chairman again for your question
again
um the ppp for those
businesses that got it and remember was
the smaller
up to 500 employees the main street
businesses the
backbone of you know our state it was to
replace
revenue loss from the pandemic so
in terms of you know businesses that
didn't qualify
and i apologize for having forgotten the
number of the senate pass bill but
it probably is in your committee mr
chairman where we
on a going forward basis um
make any further um
[Music]
similar programs from the feds eligible
for those newer businesses i think
had we been writing uh this
payroll protection plan in the new
hampshire legislature
as opposed to the u.s congress we
probably would have um thought of that
but
you know we can't control what happened
and i will say
that when congress passed this and again
having been there um
it passed in warp speed in the end of
the end of
march and it is so rare that you have
the bipartisan consensus that
you know you had the pass the cares act
um a year ago it was actually rather
remarkable and it was very necessary and
it wasn't perfect um so
i i think the senate has sent to you
a bill that will impact um
positively i think newer businesses and
let's also remember that governor sununu
established the main street program
um and i i've forgotten exactly
how much federal money of the cares act
discretionary money that came to new
hampshire
um went into the main street program but
it was a lot of
dollars and i know that in my area there
were businesses that didn't get ppp
that did get main street and so
i think that we've all tried to be
responsive to
and will continue to be responsive to
you know those businesses that
maybe didn't qualify initially for ppp
senator could you send me
that information on that bill because i
called the bill
yeah i believe uh
representative major was in one of the
omnibus bills but i will get you that
okay thank you any further questions for
senator breitbart
sand none thank you thank you mr
chairman
the next one that signed up to talk in
favor
of the bill is david gervais
lobbyist representing the business and
industry association
dave just promoted him he should be here
shortly
yes thank you mr chair uh
for the record my name is dave juvent
senior vice president with the business
and industry association
mr chair could you ask staff to also
authorize
steve lawler who is who is in the
queue to join me uh steve lawler is a
principal at
nathan wexler here in town and he's the
chair of bia's fiscal policy committee
he's a cpa
and i'm going to rely on him to answer
specific questions about how
this would work also the types of
businesses that receive ppp
loans and uh questions that
um both the chair and and representative
ames brought up about
um what happens if this bill moves
forward
yes can you yeah i did you should thank
you
uh so let me go ahead and start out uh
mr chair members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity again my name is
dave giuve i'm a senior vice president
with the business and
industry association we are very
supportive of this bill
i thought senator bradley did a terrific
job outlining
the bill why it's necessary and what's
going around
on around the country relating to this
issue
so i don't have a lot to add to that
although i'd be happy to respond to
questions from the committee i would
like to say that it is
bias analysis and also the analysis of
steve lawler
that that exemption for states
that are coming into conformity with the
latest
irs guidelines can use
that new money from the american
recovery act
to supplement any revenue loss
it's equally clear to us that other
things that are written in the house
past version of the budget like the
reductions in the um
business taxes and uh other
reductions in the rooms and meals tax
and so on
would likely not qualify but because
this bill
brings new hampshire into conformity
with the most recent irs guidelines it's
our analysis
uh that it would qualify but obviously
um
we're all waiting for clarification from
the treasury department
um mr chair i'll end my testimony there
but i would like to turn it over to
steve lawler now for some additional
comments and then we're
happy to answer any questions okay mr
lawler
you have to thank you very much mr
chairman
um i'd like to just clarify a few things
um
there were a number of businesses that
did get the the payroll protection
uh loan money um they did
use it for payroll they kept people on
um they kept their businesses open where
they may have closed
they used that money to pay the people
that didn't have to go on employment
they limped along and they got to
um the end of the year they may have
broke even
between they were able to for revenue
and what they had for expenses which
would included that payroll
but there isn't a lot of money left over
to pay the business profit tax
if they had to do that and i think
that's where the federal government
when they initially institute the cares
act
and also that they realized that
businesses this money was a lifeline for
businesses and
to have them pay tax on that at the end
of the day
would have been a burden because then
they didn't have it then they may have a
close shop and they made to have people
to
um go on unemployment so
um not all businesses but there was a
number of businesses
that and at the time are very worried
because
construction workers what needs to be
done to protect the house
tomorrow could you okay okay sorry
so i just want to make people aware of
that um
not necessarily was a windfall but there
was you know people kept their
businesses alive
they got their people employed and not
actually have to pay a tax on that
you know could be a significant burden
thank you okay thank you for your
testimony questions from the committee
representative ames followed by
representative schamberg
yeah thank you uh mr lawler
my question is uh is what
you mentioned you mentioned uh
businesses coming to the end of the year
and
they've scraped by and ppp has been very
helpful
um i'm wondering about uh
whether they've been paying the state
tax dra has been quite clear
that our situation until
sb3 or something changes it applies
to a forgiven loan and
so have in your experience to your
knowledge have
firms been paying
either by estimate or by return uh
tax on these uh forgiven loan proceeds
or is it too early to know or can you
speak to that
um a couple things uh one is
you only get taxed upon the forgiveness
and
um there was a number of companies that
haven't gotten their forgiveness yet so
that would be a 2021
issue um i think
not what i've seen is that it was not
worked into estimated tax formulas
um with the hope that it would be not
taxable
at the state
thank you just follow up
just just to be clear so so in your
experience
uh based on what you've seen what you
know
um the uh
the esc the increase in revenues that we
are harvesting in new hampshire
that's one word that seems almost
applicable since the revenues are so
high
it isn't hasn't been affected by
uh payments of this uh
state level tax that uh firms expect
will be refunded later on
or whatever you know this this is
not related can you speak to them
um it the only reason i could speak to
it is i think it gave a lifeline to a
lot of businesses
which ended up doing better but they
would have never been able to stay open
if they weren't able to get this
lifeline
thank you
representing
representatives i thought you were
go ahead yes thanks thank you mr
chairman
uh is mr uh duvet still on the line i am
thank you uh my question has to deal
with
the state has priorities as uh as does
other organizations
in new hampshire if expenses paid for
with pp loans
or amounts remain deductible which means
a reduction
which would mean a reduction in taxable
revenue for the state
from normal times what happens to the
priorities of uh
supporting adequate funding to health
care providers for medicaid and other
publicly supported health care
programs and what happens to the
priority of supporting net metering
policies that do not result in cost
shifting and the last part is what
happens these priorities
for adequate investment in new
hampshire's road and bridges if
if we're if we're allowing the
pp loans to be also deductible
well i'll start on that but i might want
to turn it over to steve lawler
so okay i don't know that the net
metering issue
um which is primarily on on the tariff
that's paid to
customers who are engaged in net
metering has anything to do
with this or state revenues and
to a great extent
the highway program it relies on the
highway user taxes paid into the state's
highway fund which again
is not impacted by this legislation
uh you know one way the state can
pay for uh priorities is is through
the uh vast
increase in in business tax collections
far beyond what was
expected and and i think we can all
agree that the economy
even though we're still you know
hampered by the pandemic the economy
seems to be getting
stronger at least that's what we're
hearing from our members who have many
open positions that they can't even find
people to fill
so there's every indication that the
economy is going to continue to get
stronger not weaker
now in terms of i think the specific of
your question relating to the
deductibility of
of business expenses i i am hoping steve
lawler can address that better than i
could
um my understanding of the
representative's
question was that if the money wasn't
there
how would you prioritize other um state
needs
was that your question representative
a in a way i just we're not
we're not counting this revenue we're
not double counting this revenue but we
seem to be taken
and a deductible of applying this
money spp loans as deductible
expenses that
weren't even counted in the beginning i
understand what the policy is i'm just
trying to figure out
how much money we're maybe going to lose
on this
well if i could if if we're right in our
analysis
um representative and yes the state
is able to use that new
income coming to the state from the um
american recovery
act to supplement any loss
that results from bringing the state
into compliance with newer
irs guidelines there is no revenue loss
okay thank you sir
are you all set representative
schoenberg yes i
am mr chairman thank you representative
thank you on i had
three questions one of them
is how many new hampshire businesses
have more than 500 employees
i've always thought that that was very
few it's a large business
in new hampshire it's a very large
business in new hampshire at 500.
it's a small business medium business
apparently elsewhere
yeah representative all me i'm sorry i
don't have access to that information
i'm not sure if someone from dra
could respond to that or if you could
check with business and economic affairs
i do agree with you
in the grand scheme of things throughout
the country 500 employees would not be
considered a
large business but here in new hampshire
the scale is different
we do we already want to be testifying
later yeah and we could check i don't
know if employment security
could tell us also um
but the second one is probably something
that
that you haven't worked on either which
is how many of these businesses are part
of water's edge filings
that is they are subsidiaries or
or subcontract i haven't figured out yet
whether
subcontractors sometimes are considered
subsidiaries
in water's edge in dra and that may be a
question for
for the dra again we we don't have
access
the bia doesn't have access to
information about who
filed for a for a ppp loan and
of those which had the loans forgiven so
again i wouldn't be able to answer that
question
and well i don't know if you can answer
this one but you may have
better ideas than anybody else we could
ask
uh we we got access to a spreadsheet
which is maintained supposedly
uh for the federal government about how
many
uh which ppp loans are in each town
in the state on and
almost all of the ones that i checked in
my town of
city of lebanon are not forgiven yet
so on is it true generally across the
state i see
mr lalor nodding his head
that on the forgive forgiving process
is just starting because i'd understood
it was going pretty
fast yeah representative um
when they passed uh the next uh
i think it was the the act that right at
the end of december
a lot of the banks were scrambling to
get new ppp loans
out and a lot of the banks put on the
forgiveness process on hold
i was looking at a bank this morning
that is only going to be
accepting applications for forgiveness
up to 150 000
over 2 million so all those
loans that were for that were given in
between that cannot apply yet
um so i think that's where the
ready to apply there's just been some
slowness in
the application process
representative spillsbury thank you mr
chairman uh this is for either uh miss
kishivey or mr lawler
um and it it gets uh pretty much to the
question that i was asking senator
bradley
uh but essentially
hb3 seems to be motivated by a concern
that we should not have businesses who
are receiving a lifeline
exposed to incremental tax liability
for the funds that the government
provided them
but if they managed to
or do manage to have that loan excused
it's only because they did with the
funds exactly what was
intended and that is used them primarily
for payroll expense
and for other qualified expenses all of
which are deductible expenses
so if every dollar of ppp
which has been excused was excused
exclusively because it was offset by
a dollar of qualified expenses how can
there be
any incremental exposure to business
profits tax
is the presumed harm
actually an illusion
i'll let steve lawler address that
question we did
stephen i did chat about that issue
yesterday so
uh steve as well
i mean it comes to the point is
as i talked in the beginning my
testimony there are businesses out there
that
yes they did use it for payroll
and they used it as a lifeline to keep
their doors
open now the cash isn't there for them
to pay the business profit tax
on that additional revenue that the
ppp forgiveness would um
would cause um because they used all
that money they would have closed their
doors
and they would have not had the people
on payroll
a restaurant that was closed
but they got the ppp money and kept
paying their people
and then they may reopened again um they
made a little profit before the end of
the year
so now maybe they broke even because of
their expenses versus a little bit of
profit that they could make because they
were only open for a short period of
time
and now and they got the ppp money to
help them get through that
and they pretty much broke even but now
there's no money left in order to pay
the taxes
so brief follow-through please all
just tracking what you said this is the
way i interpret it
they consumed all of the ppp funds
for qualified expenses thus exhausting
the cash flow that was incrementally
available to them
meaning they don't have any cash to pay
tax liabilities but there are no tax
liabilities associated
with that amount of ppp funds because
they were entirely offset by deductions
so the only tax liability would be from
business as usual
i right but there may not have been
business as usual if they weren't able
to keep their doors open
there either were profits that are
taxable where there were no time
no profits that are taxable
they yeah because they were able to keep
their doors open and they were to work
they made a little bit of money but they
broke even from a revenue standpoint
an expense standpoint and now if you add
that additional
income from the ppp loan forgiveness
there isn't the funds there to pay for
it
thank you thank you
uh next would be representative bronson
here uh this question will be for mr
lawler i'm just following up on uh
representative ames's um question
i i i guess what we're interested in
a little bit more on is we're ahead as
of yesterday
71 million in business taxes revenues
which i've been on ways of means for 11
years we've never seen a month like this
uh so we're suspecting that it may have
something to do with
all of what we're discussing here but
you but
mr you said that not really
um maybe some of it but uh
because of this the new interesting
comment you made was upon forgiveness
that that
this event doesn't happen until the loan
is actually forgiven which is
very helpful to to uh that was that i
wasn't aware of that
so so when we look at
taxable year 20 and taxable year 21
what you're saying is that there really
weren't that many loans
forgiven in in in 20 is
can you get a little more light to any
knowledge about
what percentage of the loans were were
forgiven in 20 verses that are still
being forgiven
21 uh that will be forgiven in 21.
see that'll help us try to understand
this whole
is this some of this due to uh people
paying their taxes
uh without this bill being passed to
comply with current statute
and that expecting a refund later on if
the bill passes i can't give you a
percentage of how many were forgiven
before
the end of 2020 and the end of 21. i can
only give you what my experiences
and what i've seen through my client
base um we do
we did have a number of people that had
their loans forgiven before the end of
what has happened with those businesses
is
their they are realized that there is
a bill that is working its way through
um that was passed in the the senate and
is working its way through the house
um and what they have done is extended
their
returns in essence in order to see what
the outcome was
um and either paid
paid based on current law or is waiting
to see
what the the outcome will be and and pay
their taxes
at that particular time okay
well thank you that's helpful thank you
yeah thanks
any further questions of represent
i i do have one comment that is over the
weekend i talked to a
an accountant and he asked
what are we doing with the senate bill 3
and i said we're working on it he says
good he says because he had a lot of
customers
who have been paying the tax
because they're using current law and
if this passes as is
then they're going to be asking for
refunds right
away and so
what we need to understand is this
windfall
of taxes that we're getting from the bbt
right now the business taxes how much of
that is associated
with paying the tax on the bppt
on on the ppp loans
and then if senate bill 3
passes as it is then that will turn the
thing around
that as he said
there'd be a lot of requests for refunds
or
reduce ccos
so i from what i've heard today
we don't know what that is but we need
to ask the dra that
any further questions for a
representative for mr gervais
or mr lala
and then thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chair members of the
committee we appreciate the opportunity
thanks again thank you i have one more
person
signed up to testify in support of the
bill
with mike summers i do not see a mike
summers in the attendees
but there are three other people with
their hands raised
uh christy merrill is first
okay
and are they all in the attendees
all in attendees yup go ahead let's
bring
christy morrow merrell
good morning my name is christy merrill
i'm president of the new hampshire
bankers association
um we're monitoring this legislation we
don't have an official position
um i did want to just offer to help with
any questions and
i did want to try to specifically
address a couple of questions that came
up
um both representative almi and i
believe representative abrami asked
questions about forgiveness
um i did just want to add that the
forgiveness process has started
there was a delay i know that the sba
was trying to work through and so they
had
a deadline of 90 days the sba had a
deadline of 90 days to issue their
decision
unforgiveness once a bank processed that
there were many loans that were sort of
held over past that 90 day mark and the
banks were looking for guidances in
terms of
when that forgiveness might happen and
how that might come
to my knowledge as of the state that has
not yet been resolved
and that was that was not uh that was
sort of the exception by and large with
forgiveness was happening
on a fairly rapid basis and that that's
i haven't heard anything contrary to
that with this most
second round with this uh most recent
round of ppp funding
um and then representative abrami i know
that you asked the question of the
percentage
of forgiveness versus not forgiveness
in the various rounds i don't have those
percentages for you
but what i can tell you is that it was
the majority or the overwhelming
majority of loans
that were forgiven um and certainly
banks
were working with their their customers
to try to
get them so that way their loans could
be forgiven and would try to
recommend in working with the business
owner how they use it so that way that
it could try to be forgiven
um and you know the only other comment
that i would make
in terms of the forgiveness and and what
the intent was behind congress
it is our view that it was intended to
to really be
a grant and i think the fact that
congress came back
and they expanded what what qualified
as an eligible expense the fact that
that was expanded
um is consistent with our sort of
interpretation that
congress really designed this to be a
grant
in the case that others couldn't use it
for those eligible expenses than it is
alone
and my understanding is that that is
that is really
um as i said i don't have percentages
but that's really the minority
of the ppp applications that were
approved
thank you for your testimony you take
questions
mrs merrill will you take a take
i will gladly i'm sorry okay
representative
romney followed by representative elmi
thank you mr chair
uh thank you miss merrill for taking my
question um so
i just want to make sure i understand
now when did when did the forgiveness
begin um it began
fairly soon after the first round i mean
the the program
started over a year ago so um the
forgiveness process started
i forget now and there have been so many
changes and guidances but
um relatively quickly there was a little
bit of delay in the process in terms of
how that was going to happen and
everything but um
i mean i i want to say within the first
couple of months
okay so follow up mr chair follow up
so uh so you're uh make sure i
understood what you said it sounded like
you feel that a lot of the forgiveness
has happened i do i i do with respect to
round one
as i said many banks were concerned
there were
there were loans um in there that they
held that were not yet forgiven that
were past that 90 days and the rules
said that the sba had 90 days and so
they they're anxious to get those
um forgiven but that was the the
exception rather than the rule
uh uh no second follow-up mr chair
follow up uh miss merrill so uh
so the round two the second draw uh was
another 290 billion is that correct
something like that i believe so i don't
have those total numbers right in front
of me but i believe so
290 billion so uh but but so
uh there's still may 31st is that is
it's my understanding from dra that
there's still 50 billion remaining in
that
that and so so i guess additional loans
are still going to be
coming do you have any information on
that yes i do let me just grab my notes
if i can
okay as of earlier this week there is 30
billion left in the program
and so they expect that that will run
out to the price to the program's end
and you probably know this but as a
reminder the program
ends on may 31 but there's an additional
30 days
beyond that to process applications that
are pending
and again uh one more follow-up mr chair
oh
so all of yes all of that this uh
second draw which because it was it
passed in december
really is going to affect 21 taxes is
that correct
i'm sorry i i did not catch the last
part of what you said
so since the since that law was passed
at the end of december
everything we're talking about in the
second draw really was effects
uh 21 fiscal taxable year 21 is that
correct
i believe so but i would just say that i
do not profess to be a tax
expert and and could be wrong in my tax
years okay
we'll we'll talk to dra about that thank
you
okay before i go to represent army
you keep hearing about the first
and the second uh bpp
loan program the first one
went from april 2020 to
august 31st of 2020.
the second one which we're in now
started 1-121
it goes to may 31st 21.
so there's probably almost another five
weeks left
for people to apply and then uh
looks like christy merrill just said
that there's about 30 billion dollars
left there
of the total okay uh
representative elmi
[Music]
thank you mr chairman on
ms merrill there on we found a website
called
federalpayon.com
which
representative i believe you're a mute
uh i can't bring these things up and
stay unmuted
at the same time federal federalpay.org
which on says that is linked from
the small business administration and
says that it is responsible for
reporting all of these loans
and that's the one i was talking about
earlier where um
i was looking through uh
the zip code which is most of lebanon
and
um recognized a fair number of the
people and
the businesses sometimes only by
by a certain amount of thought on
and on
almost all of them were reported as
neither repaid nor forgiven yet
and i'm wondering if there is another
site somewhere or organization that we
could
could ask that would tell us
how many how many loans have already
been forgiven in new hampshire or even
nationally because
it looks like that website must be
seriously out of date
it also had a lot of inaccuracies in it
but
thanks representative i'm not familiar
with the website um i will tell you that
we
we do try to track the data here in new
york new hampshire pretty closely
we represent 38 members 38 member banks
new hampshire chartered
out of state chartered as well as
nationally chartered banks
and of those 37 participated in the ppp
the one bank that did not participate
um does not offer commercial lending so
that's why they didn't participate
um so to answer your question
i've not i've never seen that number
reported i'm not saying that it's not
available
but um we do try to track this closely
i've never seen the number reported as
to the number of loans forgiven
um the sba.gov website i i believe it's
sba dot or slash ppp.gov
i apologize something along those lines
they do publish all their data they i
think they release that
every monday or every tuesday and that
gives you a running
tally of what's left it also gives a
breakdown by state but i've not seen the
number of forgiveness so
that really is the best i would just say
to give to go to the sba in new
hampshire
to try to answer that question if they
can give it out they would have it um
and similar the the first program you're
right that um
they did release everyone every company
that got
got a loan um after the first round was
completed you can find that by state and
so we did sort of collect that data look
at that at new hampshire
i think they they gave a range between
two and 10 million
um they didn't give the exact loan
amount so i suspect
once this the second round closes we'll
see another
uh release of data i would expect that
to be consistent i don't know that
um but i would expect some additional
information but to my knowledge i have
not seen the forgiveness the one
thing that i might be able to do is
survey our members
um but you know the the banks are all
very busy right now and so
i try to be selective and and what
information i try to get from them
are you also representing army
yeah you're muted
are you all set representing army on
yeah uh
yes i think we need to contact sba new
hampshire
i don't know how we do that but
thank you representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman um miss maryland
i'd like you to just confirm that i've
got an understanding correctly it's a
prelude to a question i want to post
so am i correcting understanding that
the ppp essentially deputized the banks
or members of your association
to manage the funds and
determine a qualification to receive ppp
and now their follow-up role is to
certify that the funds were
used appropriately before qualifying
them
for the forgiveness is that correct
basically the banks
are reviewing the expenses and the use
of the funds in order to certify that
they qualify for forgiveness
um representative in terms of the final
forgiveness my understanding is that
that final decision
is made by the sba in terms of what is a
qualified
expense when a bank is working with a
customer they might walk them through to
help them understand what the eligible
expenses are and sort of make
suggestions to them basically
in terms of how to get those loans
forgiven but um
ultimately that final decision is made
by the sba in terms of forgiveness
okay thank you so here's my question
if an amendment were prepared to sb3
that essentially stated any
qualifying expenses that were
deployed against ppp in order to obtain
debt forgiveness cannot then be
used as deductions from income
[Music]
that would otherwise go into the bpt
calculation
what would your reaction to that
amendment be or do you think that
amendment would essentially counter the
purpose of hp3
well if i'm understanding your question
um so it as i it sounds like the root of
your question is that you're concerned
that a small business owner may be
granted forgiveness based on eligible
expenses but also getting an additional
tax benefit is that
a correct substantially using it in two
ways
to get a double deduction
what an amendment that precluded them
from
using the same expense twice
um how would you view that
um well you know as i as i said in in
the beginning we don't officially have a
position obviously we have an interest
in knowing the outcome
um as our members are processing a lot
of these applications
but i i guess what i would say and i
don't know if it's
of help to you or not but i think what
they're the banks are finding
is that when um a small business owner
puts in an application
and obviously you know everyone would
love to see a hundred percent of
forgiveness um there's some type of
combination
it's not either entirely forgiven or
or not it's it's really a combination so
they might be able to
use you know 40 40 to 60 percent
on qualifying expenses but there's a
there's a remaining balance there
so um i you know i i wouldn't take a
position on that that's all i guess i
can say
and um i apologize if that's not really
helpful for you
all right actually that's very helpful
so in other words an amendment of that
sort
might have to be worded to the extent
that
uh expenses resulted in
a complete or partial
forgiveness dot dot dot i thank you i
think it's very helpful
further questions uh for
mrs merrill uh
hold on a second the resonating thank
you
mrs merrill representative major i can
send along contact information for the
new hampshire sba office if that would
be helpful to you all
thank you uh
we do have mike summers
and the attendees so if you could let
mike summers in
done
mike summers has signed up as a lobbyist
with new hampshire lodging and
restaurant association and support
mike summers go ahead
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee i apologize for
uh missing my uh point in online we have
multiple hearings going on i was
juggling things and so i apologize
um and and appreciate you taking the
time to allow me to uh
to follow up with you but um
for the record mike summers of the
president ceo of the new hampshire
lodging and restaurant association
as i'm sure you're aware our industry
has been very hard hit by this uh
pandemic as we try to come out of it
uh i testified before this committee i
believe was a couple of months ago now
kind of tried to give an overview of
where we had come from and what we had
hoped for the future
um but i i guess i'm here to ask today
that uh
first of all that you support support
sb3 i think
uh tax exemption of ppp is is the least
we should be doing for these small
businesses who are struggling
i i will tell you i continue to get
phone calls from restauranteurs
specifically but many hotels as well
that are legitimately hanging on by the
fingernails and frankly their
their lot probably isn't going to
improve any time before july 4th weekend
um so i you know i just i ask you to be
sensitive and i appreciate the fact that
you know you have a very difficult job
trying to figure out how we're going to
fund the state for the next biennium
i get that um but i but i think what
what i'd like to ask of you is to also
consider
uh potentially uh exempting
the uh the cares act funds the the
main street relief funds and others to
also be included
i don't know if it can be done
specifically for our industry i suspect
not but
we're certainly requesting that because
there are many businesses right now
that are in in dire straits and as uh
has been mentioned a number of times in
this discussion today
we have um the purposes of these funds
was to keep our employees
at work and and off the unemployment
rolls and and
keep kept in place and and so that to
the
a couple of points that i believe
senator bradley made it was successful
in that effect and
it seems uh i will just say that from
many industry folks that i've spoken to
it is very frustrating that
they have fought and and scrabbled to
get to this point
to then have the state potentially step
in and ask them for a portion of
whatever aid they received in order to
prop up their businesses
um and and for those of you who have
restaurant uh business owners as friends
i think you can appreciate that
uh they're a pretty independent lot they
don't like to ask for aid or assistance
but this was the year they needed it so
um that is my appeal to you
and uh with that i will close and i'd be
happy to try to answer
any questions you may have thank you for
your testimony
uh mr sanders i do have a question
is how many in your organization
have contacted you because they weren't
allowed
or qualified to get these ppp loans
so there were some uh for the most part
they were larger businesses
and again you know you would anticipate
larger businesses
had a little more equity a little more
where with all but there were some
groups that certainly did not qualify
surprisingly it was more on the lodging
side the hotel side where folks did not
qualify for a variety of reasons and so
there definitely were i'd be
hard-pressed to give you a
a percentage or a number uh
representative but but there were a fair
number of businesses that did not
qualify
what i will also add as as a qualifier
is
you know when it came to the main street
relief there were even more folks that
didn't qualify for a variety of reasons
and how those uh programs were
structured as well and so
as we look at this there are a fair
number of businesses that
uh again when i say they're hanging on
by their fingernails i don't think that
i'm really
understating their position well thank
you uh representative brundy
thank you mr chair uh thank you mr
summers um can we just focus on the main
street program a second
um how is that structured uh
uh is it is it were they grants to the
businesses
was it similar to ppp or can you help us
out with that
i i know i don't i can't remember how
that was structured yeah and i
forgive forgive me my understanding is
probably cursory because i wasn't
actually didn't go through the process
but
ultimately the way this worked it was it
was a pass-through from
uh the federal cares act monies came
into the state and then the governor
and the gopher committee decided how to
distribute those funds
but ultimately that money came through
and was distributed to businesses
uh based on it on a need basis um and it
was given uh
as as as uh forgivable grants
but couple of caveats so the first is uh
the grants maxed out at 350
000 and frankly there were a lot of
people that got much much less than that
um but then there is also we have just
gone through a true up process where
um there was a calculation that was
required to be done and reporting
uh to dra where they had to take their
2019 sales deducted 2020 sales deduct um
uh ppp and whatever that difference was
uh
you know deduct main street from that
and then if
you were in the in the black then that
money will likely have to be returned to
the to the state
um but there are an awful lot of
businesses that were still in the red at
the end of those calculations
and so um i think to the crux of your
question representative i think
uh there was simply a pass-through grant
from
karzak money through the state to the
businesses
mr follow up mr chair but
again you wanted to roll this into this
bill
so so is that that grant taxable at the
moment
yes okay that's what i was trying to
consider an income of the business and
again i
i did follow up with dra to confirm that
but yes the grant monies uh will will be
treated as income of the business and
you know i'll go a step further we now
have a third round of aid that are going
to businesses which is the restaurant
revitalization fund which you may have
heard of as part of their most recent
package
and those grants was just announced
today that that grant portal will open
on may 3rd so there is going to be
another round of grant funding
that will go specifically primarily to
restaurants and so
again that's going to be another tax
liability potentially for these
businesses as
as we get into next year but
follow up again is it the grandest taxes
or is it really
after the grant is it the uh
if they still not profitable will there
be
there won't be business taxes correct
assumption yes yeah we'll follow up with
the dra we'll
follow the dra i'm sorry yes thank you
uh further questions of mr sunderland
cnn thank you for your testimony thank
you sir appreciate your time uh
we have one more journey
yes uh michael benton
vladimir yep
thank you uh unfortunately i was unable
to register in time for today's meeting
and i thank you for the moment
i am a business owner uh and
significantly benefited from ppp
uh i employ about 250 people in the
state
and have gone through the process i'd
like to just make one thing
obvious that ppp did
more than provide the lost revenue
it provided my business with the ability
to stay afloat because the it wasn't
just the lost revenue
it was the lost profits i was shut down
for four months
without those funds i would have gone
out of business
all the employees i was able to maintain
not just my employees but i was also
able to maintain the future of my
business
and if you say that we mix accounting
uh with the fact that i'm taking an
expense
against money that was granted to me to
stay alive
uh we're mixing we're confusing the
point the point is
it's not an accounting issue it truly
was money that was needed from the
federal government to keep my business
alive
and and to mix that with i will be able
to take a deduction
confuses the situation because quite
honestly
the money that was was given to me not
only was given to me to stay alive
it's also been given to me to allow as
consumer confidence in my business
grows and and as we exit this pandemic
i've lost even more revenue that
that i require for the for my for the
future of my business
so i'm speaking on behalf of a
businessman in the state
who is gone through this process very
painfully
none of us asked for this and the ppp
funds were critical
and as as i believe the accountant
stated
at the end of the day you don't have the
money to pay tax on top of the money
that you receive to stay alive
so if i can answer any questions
relative i have gone i have just filed
for forgiveness
the process with my bank uh was
very confusing uh but we we have gotten
through that we we weren't even allowed
to apply
until the beginning of march of this
year through my banking at lending
institution
we did apply the bank went through that
process
as i exited that process the bank
basically
sanitized all of my forgiveness 100
of the ppp funds i received went to
payroll
there were no other expenses it 100 went
to payroll
and then from that point it now goes to
the sba
i'm still not forgiven i've only gotten
through the bank process
now the sba has 90 days i have 10 months
from the time i was funded to actually
apply
so i was kind of gated by the bank but
we've met those guidelines
so hopefully i will receive forgiveness
from the sba
and my loan will then turn to a grant if
that doesn't happen
then starting september i will then be
my loan will have to start to be repaid
so i'm hoping very much that
that the loan will be forgiven by the
sba
thank you for your testimony mr ben
questions for mr benton
representative thank you mr chairman
uh mr benton on
which what sector are you in i'm in the
health and fitness industry now
health and fitness thank you very much
and
on you were in round one
yes ma'am and they wouldn't you weren't
allowed to apply for gift
for forgiveness until march so
the websites were not available uh
and then when the second round hit the
banks uh
were there was a lot of confusion with
the with the with my particular bank and
i don't believe i'm
uh um uh an exception to this
uh so that we weren't really allowed or
in a position to actually use their
website
to start the forgiveness process
representative
thank you that's that's really helpful
to know and
i'm sorry for for
what you're going through the thing that
i'd like to point out is the consumer
confidence at least in my sector and i
think that's true for the hospitality
and restaurant sector is still not there
probably 30 percent of my business is
gone
now i'm hoping to get that back and and
that's going to be a process
over time so these funds like i said
we're not just for the immediate to
cover my
there for my future so to pay tax
on top of what we receive will be a huge
burden
a year from now
other questions of mr benton
uh representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman uh just a brief
question mr benton
uh i'm certain that you've been through
a struggle and i appreciate it and i
applaud
you if 100 of your pp loans
were used for payroll why do you fear
any exposure to tax on those funds
well the payroll is an expense so if you
take the opinion that
it's irrelevant whether i used it for
rent or used it for payroll i was able
to deduct it
and but i didn't look at the accounting
process of being able to deduct
something
from the federal government that was
given as a as aid
to get me through the four months in
which i was shut down and there's where
i believe we're confusing accounting
principles with
what that money was truly intended to do
which was to give it to us to support
our businesses to keep us open to keep
our employees
off the the uh the unemployment rates
which by the way that's another very
important piece they gone to the
unemployment rates
i would have never been able to open
back up in july
had i not kept those employees who knows
what would have happened
to try and get them back so it was
incredibly important for us to be able
to maintain
not just keep them off the unemployment
ranks but to basically have them
available as we when we open to back
up so and that is true with the second
round
to be able to maintain uh uh
future and and as we continue to wait
for consumer confidence at least in our
industry and i believe that's true in
hospitality and restaurants
the restaurant industry to be able to
wait for that consumer confidence to
come back
because i don't believe any of us back
in september thought january was going
to be the month that it was in terms of
the pandemic
and that significantly impacted our
businesses again
so i i would hate to think that we
confuse
accounting practices on how businesses
were able to retain these funds
with the need to retain them to keep our
businesses whole
not just for now but into the future
because we've lost not just the revenue
we've lost the profits
and those profits allow us not just to
pay taxes they allow us to continue to
grow our businesses in the state
thank you are you all set representative
all set thank you any further questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
mr ben anybody else wished
to testify for or against
saying then i'm going to ask the dra
uh if you would like
major yes uh
jerry stringham just put his hand up
okay we do i don't know okay
yes are you hearing me okay yes yeah
um very very good seeing you all
i just wanted to draw from my own
experience with the ppp
i think representative spillsberry uh
has uh the math correct um
i received a ppp as part of my business
to the extent that the employees that i
was able to retain with the ppp were
productive
and enhanced my revenues
you know that becomes uh that becomes
profitable
and um to the extent
that there would be no business i would
have been able to write off
and it did write off all of those uh
expenses
uh last year and i would not be paying
any uh
any bpt uh on on the ppp money that i
received
um what the mechanism for
receiving um uh the funds and the
forgiveness i did receive
the funds last year uh it went into the
books as alone
uh his uh it was still officially alone
as of the first of the year
as the loan forgiveness paperwork um
wasn't completed until march so it'll
show up as
as as income
non-taxable for federal purposes in my
2021 uh income but all the payroll and
everything that uh
and other um uh expenses that were part
of the justification for the ppp
uh what actually um was incurred
last year um
you know personally i have no problem
paying
um uh business profit tax
uh in in the state of new hampshire uh
for the apportioned part of the revenue
that's associated with new hampshire
because you know that those funds really
came in
pretty much similar to the way that any
other grant or revenue comes into the
business
and it was very helpful and appreciated
uh and to the extent um uh
that uh you know the rest of the
revenues and profits uh held up
i'd be paying the same amount of same
amount of tax
i think there would be a difference you
know for for a struggling business with
a bet
which you can pay even if you're you're
um
even if you're unprofitable so
um uh
uh you know while past speakers have
talked about you know the ability to
retain profits is important for future
growth
i think um uh i'm okay keeping
uh most of it and
paying some some for the state for the
opportunity
to thrive and succeed in the granite
state
and you know i think the pro
program worked pretty well and it
doesn't it doesn't need to be tax-free
uh to um uh to meet its purpose
uh in fact but in in part by making it
uh taxable uh for those that it really
helped
provide a lifeline to they wouldn't be
paying b
uh bpt anyway and for those who it was
just uh
additional uh revenue and additional
bottom line
the bpt tax would go up a bit
so um uh my
you know like in light of what what i've
heard from the committee and from the
others
i thought i would add my own perspective
i hope it was helpful
and be happy to answer any questions
that you might have
thank you jerry always good to hear from
you
uh questions representative hacken
phillips
mr chair uh and thank you mr stringham
for taking my question i'm just
wondering what your
business industry might be which sector
do you participate
yeah i'm a i'm a consultant
with employees in in multiple states in
the healthcare
technology field
so we help companies that
are developing new medical products
are you all set okay uh representative
abrami
thank you mr chair uh my buddy here uh
former representative stringham
um i'm trying to glean from this uh
are you supporting would you support
this bill if you were with us
uh
i i would support i would support the
status quo that the uh
bpt uh the ppp not be deducted from the
uh
uh from the top line revenue the company
or that it
so so you'd be a no vote
on this bill i believe so yeah okay just
want to clarify that thank you
further questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
jerry
oh representative tommy did you have a
question
oh it was representative tucker she has
her hand i i don't have a question but i
do have a comment
i'm addicted to the new hampshire
business reviews book of lists
and i happen to have in front of me the
2020 magazine
i spill coffee on the cover so i no
longer have a cover
on my copy but the it's a
compilation of a magazine of all of
companies of any size industries
in new hampshire and on many of them
it lists the number of employees
and it is probably the most easy to
obtain
way to find out you know how big a
company is
and it's very interesting how well the
top
manufacturing companies in the state
are mostly foreign owned that have over
employees and a tremendous number of
employees are at dartmouth hitchcock and
so forth but you can see
it it is very useful to have something
that's
accessible that has the number of
employees
and i think it's the easiest way
it's it's just very very accessible and
it has the names of the people
and their addresses and ownership so
it's all together
uh in one place so they put it out every
year
and i don't know whether uh 2021 is out
it's not what i found i found 2020
but it's when i do a business story it's
one of the places i start
so that was just because i know everyone
is interested in
because of the 500 on this
uh representative tucker thank you
anybody else have a comment or question
on senate bill 3
then i'm going to ask
someone from dre is it carolyn
or lindsay
[Music]
um
carolyn and melissa are in but i also
see uh devin rodrick i'll
i'll promote him as well good um
is lindsay there too she doesn't appear
to be anymore
no
oh yeah she's up top that always happens
they raise their hand and they jump the
alphabetical
queue okay so now we have the staff of
the dre
with us so lindsay do you have
any comments to make or good afternoon
now
mr chair members of the committee for
the record lindsey step
commissioner at the new hampshire
department of revenue administration
i thought it would be helpful if you
would indulge me for just a few minutes
i was just going to walk through and
confirm what i believe
is generally everyone's understanding
about the issue that we're talking about
here
and i will also walk through the fiscal
note
that the dra has completed and which you
received a copy of our fiscal note quick
guide
so at a high level we are talking about
the taxability
of forgiven ppp loans again importantly
these are the loans that have been
forgiven
and once they're forgiven there is
currently a difference between
the tax treatment at the federal level
and at the state level
currently at the state level ppp loans
that are forgiven become grants
and they are taxed the same as any other
grant
this means that the amount is included
in the businesses gross income
and any amounts that are spent on
deductible expenses such as wages
can be deducted so the full amount of
the forgiven
ppp loan would come into gross income
and in instances where
all of that money was spent on
deductible expenses
those expenses will be subtracted out
and the net
impact to bpt will be zero
um a tax tax would be paid on any
amounts that were not spent
or were spent on non-deductible expenses
although i
suspect that amounts spent on
non-deductible expenses would be minimal
given um the purpose of the loans which
became grants
so that's the state treatment again
coming into gross income
deductions for any expenses that are
deductible and then you're hitting
bpt for anything that is not deductible
or that was not spent
at the federal level ppp loans that have
been forgiven
are not included in gross income so they
never come into the gross income of the
business
but the expenses can still be deducted
so anytime
um the loans were spent on wages or
other deductible expenses
they would be subtracted from gross
income but the grant or forgiven loan
amount would not be included
this essentially results in an
additional benefit
you're going to be able to deduct
expenses
which don't necessarily have an
offsetting
amount in gross income so that's the
difference between the state and the
federal treatment
so what senate bill 3 does is conform us
to the federal treatment
saying that the forgiven loan amounts
the grants
for ppp would not be in gross income
but we would still businesses would
still be able
to deduct the expenses i see a couple of
hands raised so
mr chair i think i'll pause there um to
make sure we're all on the same page and
then i can talk about the fiscal note
okay uh representative molloy
thank you very much mr chair thank you
for
allowing me to ask commissioner a
question here
uh what you just read could you send
that to us in print
i would be more than happy to it's a
nice bulleted list um i refer to it
frequently
so happy to that is wonderful thank you
thank you dennis uh repton here really
yes thank you dennis
jeez the question i have we're
already in compliance with federal law
and most of our other stuff i think we
passed a couple of laws that brought
new hampshire up to uh current
conformity with irs regulations
so if we passed sb3 we would merely be
following
the same path of trying to bring the two
uh at least parallel or as close as
possible is
is that a correct analysis misstep
that's a great question so you're
correct representative ulrie over the
past few years
um we have updated our conformity to the
internal revenue code
so folks that have been on the committee
for a long time will remember that
new hampshire went for a number of years
not updating um the internal revenue
code that we reference
in the past few years we have updated so
we currently reference the code as of
december 31st of 2018.
we provide a memo to this committee
every year that talks about the
differences between the state
and federal codes the current federal
code and the state code that we
reference
i will note that when we do update our
our conformity we do often
what's called decouple from certain
provisions in the federal code
we do that for two or three different
provisions typically because the feds
have provided a very generous benefit
and
given the makeup of our tax structure
the potential fiscal impact is more
than the legislature is willing to kind
of swallow at that point
what we're talking about here you're
correct that it is a difference between
the state and federal treatment
this specific provision actually lives
outside of the internal revenue code
um so that's why we are needing to adopt
um this uh federal treatment
specifically in the language that is
referenced
in senate bill 3. so that's exactly what
senate bill 3 does is
it mirrors the federal treatment
similar to what we would do in terms of
when we are conforming
i thank you misstep like i always tell
people there are two ways to create
life one of which is to create law or
sue someone
okay represent all me followed by
representative brownlee
thank you uh
commissioner if on
what what would happen
if on we have a case like uh
ex-representative stringham square
which seems like it's going to be very
common
on they had the expenses they
they used the the loan to pay expenses
which were deductible last year and
even though they didn't have much
revenue
or any revenue last year they filed and
they deducted the expenses
and then this year they finally get the
loan forgiven
into a grant on
would if we
didn't do this would they then have to
um they would not have had any
deductible expenses to
weigh against it is what i'm trying to
say
regardless of conformity to the federal
treatment and regardless of senate bill
those expenses still remain deductible
they're spent on wages
rent general expenses that operate your
business so
there is we're not talking about any
change as to whether or not
expenses are deductible the only thing
we're talking about is whether or not
that
forgiven loan or that grant should be
treated like other grants and included
in gross income
or if you want to allow for a specific
exception to ppp grants
and have them not included in gross
income so really the only thing that
we're talking about is whether or not
that forgiven ppp amount
goes in that top gross line a gross
income number
thank you grandfather follow-up what i
was talking about
was on if you're in
on ex-representative stringham's shoes
and you reported the the expenses were
made
in 20 in tax year 20.
and but the the grant
occurs in 21 because it was a loan
before
are they allowed to take 2020 expenses
and deduct them in 2021
they will not um those expenses will
remain deductible in 20
and i think there's going to be a number
of different issues here and it's going
to be potentially on a taxpayer
tax payer by taxpayer basis there was
guidance put out by the irs
that encouraged taxpayers that if they
reasonably believed that their ppp loan
was going to be forgiven
that they could assume that forgiveness
in 20.
um obviously unclear as to whether or
not all
taxpayers followed that guidance and
there may have been a variety of reasons
why they did or did not
also it could depend on the accounting
methodologies
and various ways that taxpayers keep
their books and records
to determine where exactly the loan
forgiveness and the expenses will fall
so this is something that the cpas and
tax preparers will need to work with
businesses on
in terms of appropriately accounting for
the expenses
and also for the potential loan
forgiveness
representative browning thank you mr uh
thank you
commissioner steph for uh uh providing
the testimony
so yes we had this discussion a couple
years ago about conforming and not
conforming
and we decided not to conform uh it'd be
a couple years behind
and all of what you just said about
notifying us every year
the good example was section 179 which
was the accelerated
depreciation was the amount that was it
was really high
for the federal level and not too high
for us
uh so so on march 3rd 2020 when this
bill was signed into law
all those conforming states became
uh conformed with this ppp change
or because there was no statute on the
law that said that we would forgive
anything it was just specific to this
particular provision is that correct
correct so states that have rolling
conformity and just
kind of roll with the punches if you
will of the federal
internal revenue code changes they did
essentially generally conform to this
tax treatment
even though this does technically live
outside of the internal revenue code
those states have just adopted the
policy that we follow the federal
treatment
for taxes states that are not rolling
conformity like new hampshire and many
others are having these exact
discussions
where there is a decision whether to
affirmatively adopt this federal
treatment
or not and so that's why you see
that there are some states that have not
yet adopted this treatment new hampshire
being one of them
and why if you look back over time if
you find older news articles
you'll see that in the beginning it was
x number of states and over time
more and more states have adopted that's
because those non-rolling conformity
states
have made the affirmative decision
through legislation that's passed
through their house in their senate and
ultimately signed by their governor
to adopt this federal treatment okay
follow-up follow-up so that's
interesting so they didn't automatically
conform
they they just they chose to conform
right rolling conformity
essentially did automatically conform
but those states like new hampshire that
are static conformity
when we adopt as a specific date those
states are making this decisions
individually
thank you okay
representative spellsbury thank you mr
chairman uh
this step that last discussion you just
had with representative obama he
anticipates my question so i'm sure
you're
following those states which did not
have rolling conformity and are
making uh going through the same
discussion
uh do you have any insights to what
extent
the discussion in those states is
factoring in their ability
to draw a degree of offsetting income
through the individual income
tax so that where ppp funds have been
used
uh to make payroll um there is
a a tax uh recipe to the state
on that or in fact as employees and
others use
the uh the money spent in ppp
to go out and make purchases there may
be a sales tax
maybe harder to quantify a little bit
less direct but still
uh clearly there um so i'm i guess i'm
asking you to tell us
whether you're able to gauge how much of
a factor
those offsetting revenue sources have
been in other states who have those
sources
i can't gauge thank you for the question
i can't gauge
specifically um as to whether or not
those other states have necessarily
acknowledged that if they don't tax it
at the corporate level
that there is still tax coming in as you
mentioned at the individual
income tax level especially to the
extent that the amounts were spent on
wages
and at the sales tax level to the extent
that the employees then continue to
purchase things within the economy
um however what
however their revenue picture or their
fiscal
impact when looking at the impact of
conforming to the federal treatment is
different than the revenue
impact that you're going to see here in
new hampshire so
when my counterpart in another state
that has an income
individual income tax broad-based
individual income tax and a broad-based
sales tax
is looking at the overall fiscal impact
it is going to look different than here
in new hampshire
because while we have the negatives for
the business profits tax and other
states would as well for their corporate
income tax
we have a small corresponding
positive impact with bet which i'll talk
about when we get to the fiscal note
and other in states with a broad-based
income tax
individual income tax would have a
larger impact
positive impact at the individual income
tax level
and again at the sales tax level to the
extent that they are able to quantify it
as you said it's probably a little bit
more difficult
so their overall fiscal impact is going
to look different than it does here in
new hampshire
and that would probably would inform
their decision about whether or not to
conform
thank you so the reciprocal point i
suppose then would be
if new hampshire had either or both
a personal income tax or a sales tax
your fiscal note would look different
correct and like i said when we start
when i walk you through the fiscal note
you you will see there is a positive
impact for the business enterprise tax
because wages are taxable under the
business enterprise tax
but given that it is a much lower rate
than a typical individual income tax
rate
it's a smaller positive offset
thank you thank you for that question
representative spillsbury
but uh any further questions
then why don't you continue uh
sure happy too so the other thing that i
wanted to do with you today
was walk through our fiscal note and how
we arrived at the fiscal impact
so before we get started a couple things
to know
previous speakers have identified that
our fiscal note has
had a bit of an evolution over uh the
process as senate bill 3 has made its
way through both
the senate and now into the house i will
note that our first attempt at a fiscal
note for this bill
did have a revenue impact of
approximately negative 80 million to a
negative 135 million
um two things to note about that fiscal
note one it was extremely complicated
um and very difficult in order for us to
convey
um all of the intricacies of how that
fiscal note was derived
the second thing i will note is we heard
some testimony in the senate
um that um question some of our
methodology on that fiscal note
we take that testimony seriously and so
we kind of went back to the drawing
board
hearing some of the feedback and we're
always happy to hear feedback
so we went back to the drawing board and
developed
a more simple and we believe
a slightly more accurate fiscal note
the methodology that i'm going to
present to you this morning or this
afternoon
is our updated methodology and in the
senate that
produced a fiscal impact of a loss of
65.1 million
you'll see what you have in front of you
today has a loss of 91.7 million
the only difference there is that the
65.1 million
was using total ppp um
loans as of august 8th of 2020.
we have now updated the total ppp amount
to reflect those loans issued as of
april 18th
of 2021. so it's just
essentially updating the base of where
we're starting from
to account for essentially the second
round of ppp loans
that have been issued and again we're
only talking about ppp
loans that have been issued through
april 18th
so this analysis does not contemplate
the additional 30 billion or so
um that is still remaining that could
potentially be issued through may 31st
so the fiscal note as i said starts with
total ppp
issued as of april 18 2021
which is 762 billion dollars
we then subtract out 20 percent
for ppp that was issued to nonprofits
and to businesses that are under our
taxable thresholds of fifty thousand
dollars
that twenty 20 number is an assumption
um
and that's based on our general review
of the data for ppp
loans that were issued to new hampshire
businesses only
i'll pause here for a second you'll hear
me say multiple times as i go through
this that there's a lot of assumptions
so we are making a lot of assumptions
about the data
the data that we receive from the small
business administration is the same data
that is available to
you and to the public we don't have
taxpayer identification numbers so we're
not able to tie the data specifically
back to our individual tax records
to know how certain businesses this
might ultimately flow into their tax
return
so we're not using necessarily any of
our data or our specific information
about
taxpayers in order to arrive at this
analysis
so we are making a lot of general
assumptions
so taking the 762 billion subtracting
again 20 percent being those businesses
that are below our bpt
threshold and also those businesses that
are not subject to bpt because they're
non-profits
that arrives at 610 billion dollars
and the next thing we do is apply a 0.4
percent
apportionment to new hampshire
i've heard the committee this morning
talk a lot about new hampshire
businesses that have received ppp
and those businesses are certainly very
likely to be subject to tax here in new
hampshire
you also have businesses whose address
is not
in new hampshire that may still be
subject to tax here
regional new england businesses you may
have a business in massachusetts
that owns property or locations in both
states but their headquarters are in
massachusetts
so those businesses wouldn't show when
we're just looking at the new hampshire
data so that's why we start with the
whole pot
of total ppp because we could have
businesses across the country
that received ppp that apportioned to
new hampshire and therefore
file a tax return here in new hampshire
so that point four percent is a number
that we've used routinely over the years
it's generally based on population but
it's a way that any time we're looking
at a national number
if we want to um decide or try to
approximate
what portion is attributable to new
hampshire we use 0.4 percent
so again a number you may have seen in
our fiscal notes in the past and again
it's just trying to say
total united states what portion is new
hampshire
so applying that 0.4 you arrive at 2.4
billion
so that is our estimate of total ppp
that could be taxable here in new
hampshire
again would not include anyone that's
not subject to the bpt
and does include businesses outside of
new hampshire did a portion here
so the first thing we do is apply the
7.7
bpt rate to the 2.4 billion
and that results in just under 185
million
of additional benefit that businesses
would receive
if ppp for given ppp loans were not
included in gross income
we then start to whittle that number
down so the next thing we do
is assume that 80 of that amount
was spent on wages and therefore would
be subject to the bet
again the 80 is more than the 60 percent
that was required under the program but
you've heard some testimony this morning
that many businesses did
primarily spend these amounts on wages
so we have assumed a slightly higher
percent at eighty percent
so if eighty percent of
the two point four billion was spent on
wages that gives you two billion dollars
spent on wages
using the bet rate of 0.6 percent
results in a bet liability of 11.7
million
so we take that 11.7 million and we
reduce
that uh or take that away from 185
million
of the initial bpt loss which results in
173.1 million
so again you had a loss but as
representative spillsberry mentioned
there is some benefit there because we
have that tax
on the wages so we've reduced that loss
by
the 11.7 million
the next thing we do is um acknowledge
that we have businesses the way that our
bet mbpt
taxes interact we have businesses
who absent bet would pay bpt
but because bet isn't credit against bpt
the only thing they pay is bad and so
they wouldn't
experience this additional benefit
because their bet is in excess of their
bpt
so they always pay more in debt than
their bpt liability
so they always offset each other and
based on our analysis looking at our
data this is the one place where we
really dug into our data
approximately 47
of our taxpayers are bet only taxpayers
so again this additional benefit that
would be available
under the bpt would not impact these
taxpayers because they only pay back
so we take that reduced 173.1
million apply the 47 percent
and that's how we get to the 91.7
million
so again at a high level we took total
ppp
determined the portion that we believed
would be subject to the business profits
tax
we apportioned it to new hampshire
applied the bpt rate creating our loss
reduce that loss by the bet that was
generated because
these amounts were spent on wages and
then accounted for those taxpayers that
only pay bet
and are not bpt taxpayers and that's how
we arrive at the 91.7 million
again using total ppp issued through
april 18th
i will stop there and happy to answer
any questions
oh it looks like it looks like norm
where did norm go
well i'll i'll i'll i'll assume the
chair here roll here and i've got a
question
no uh is norm back
no okay uh commissioner um
we all got uh an email from uh you folks
it was either yesterday or this morning
um talking about the second draw
uh which started in uh uh was enacted at
the end of december and it goes to may
31st
so and new hampshire's portion of that
was going to be 290 billion
of additional loans uh and
the email said that 240 billion has
already been awarded
now we just heard testimony from bank
association she threw out a number 30
billion but i we know that's fluid so
but let's say it's 50 billion that still
still
hasn't gone out as yet um
so when when we look at the date on your
your in the fiscal note that your
starting point that
762 billion
uh was as of 418 the best of your
knowledge
uh that that still unknown is the 50
billion
as to whether those loans are going to
be made and forgiven
uh and so it would be very helpful to
the committee i think
that over the next week or two for us to
estimate
how much of that 50 billion
uh i would assume it would it would make
this estimate go up a little bit
because there's still 50 billion
unaccounted for so far as i can see
uh that may
be forgiven uh
that's you know so can you just address
that where we're at with that
whole analysis sure we'd be happy to um
update the fiscal analysis assuming
again
that the total of the second um
random pp is issued it sound like
sounded like christy alluded to the fact
that they believe that will be true so
we can certainly update
the fiscal notes using the full amount
the second thing i would note is that
this analysis
does assume that all ppp loans are
forgiven
looking at data from the sva website
is the best as i can decipher it it
looks like
to date for the forgiveness applications
that they've processed
only 0.3 percent have not been forgiven
um a very small percentage but i will
note that our analysis
does assume that everything that is
issued
will be forgiven right okay so
all right so um so even if
even if in the next couple of weeks uh
next week
can you take the maximum amount and do
your estimate
certainly that's what's going to do and
then we can assume it'll fall somewhere
between
where we're at now and the and the
maximum amount okay thank you
see uh chairman uh major everybody but i
i had to drop off because i was frozen
i couldn't communicate so i just came
back
so sorry about about that
lindsay where are we right you had just
completed
the analysis of the 91.7 million
correct and i was in the process of
making a statement
did you hear the statement i did not
hear the statement so if you'd be
willing to repeat that that would be
helpful
it's a small statement but um the
your analysis based upon as of april
18th
and then we know that this
long period extends to
application to the end of may
but there's only 30 billion left and if
you multiply that by
0.4 it's it's a small amount so it's not
going to
affect the 91.7 million
much is that a correct statement
i believe that to be a correct statement
representative abrami asked
a similar question and i did agree to
update the analysis
assuming that the total amount is issued
so we can get you an updated number the
other thing i did know
is that the analysis does assume that
all ppp will be forgiven
looking at the data that the sba has
made available to date with respect
to the processing of forgiveness it
appears as though
only point three percent of loans that
have been processed for forgiveness
have not been forgiven so it is a
relatively low percentage of loans that
are not forgiven
so our again our analysis does assume
that all ppp will be forgiven
well that's pretty good as far as an
analysis goes
we know we could rely on you guys
okay further questions of uh
i can't see that if i put participants
up
uh representative ames followed by
representing elmi
representative okay thank you um
so first uh i guess this is a a question
to the chair
um will there be a work session of
follow-up uh
to look more closely at
the um basically the fiscal note side of
this the
impact question
excellent question there definitely will
and there's probably
more than one work session because we
still
need the guidance from the treasury
thanks and uh we need
the latest up-to-date information from
the dra
and we we need to talk about this
amongst ourselves
there's a number of questions that were
raised today and we need those answers
and hold off on this until
we get that or until the as
long as we can before we execute
i think that's essential and i
appreciate that um
and then uh the immediate question is
uh related to
our surge in revenues and the question
of whether
dra knows
[Music]
if there is if there have been
revenues received that reflect payments
by
taxpayers of
taxes under the current law
on on ppp
loan proceeds that may lead
subsequently if sp3 is enacted to a
refund request
first question asked before lindsay
answers that
let me add to that is that
over the weekend i talked to my
accountant
and and he reminded me that
uh he's processed an awful lot of
returns that had to do with the ppp
loans
and they paid the taxes because they
used current law
he says that if senate bill 3 goes
through as it is
we're going to see an awful lot of
refunds
so uh i'm anxious to hear
what lindsay has to say is she able to
estimate how things are going relative
to that how much of this
excess revenue that we've been getting
now is associated
with what we may have to refund if
senate bill 3 goes through as
is sure
so i think that there's
um a couple different scenarios
that we are seeing here
the first representative major as you
mentioned
is that businesses have accounted for
ppp
um loan forgiveness in their 2020
tax returns if that is the case
they have presumably done one of two
things
they have filed and paid their tax
return
timely in either march or april
or they have paid the amount that they
owe but have not yet filed their return
and they
are taking advantage of the automatic
seven month extension
in order to file their return and will
be receiving those returns in the fall
yes let's talk about those two scenarios
first so
in the first instance where they have
filed their actual return
there is a line on our schedule
4 that asks them to report the amount of
ppp
that was not included in gross income
on their federal return but is included
in gross income
on their new hampshire return so we can
start to look at those numbers
we will need to put those amounts
through apportionment formulas and then
apply the tax
so it's it's a little bit of work for us
but we can certainly start
doing that and that will start to give
us an idea of what we've seen
for businesses that are
opting to file an extension we have
presumably the amount of money that they
owe but we don't know
what portion of that is related to ppp
because they haven't filed their final
return yet
the other scenario that we have is what
former representative stringham
mentioned
where they may be waiting for the actual
forgiveness
in order to account for that in their
return and so that may not happen until
2021.
so we can start to put some
some guardrails and framework around
what we've seen but we don't
have exact answers to that question
yeah the more knowledge we know about
this
we can prevent people from saying we
have it we can spend it now
and we've got to prevent that
or give them the knowledge so that they
can make the decision not to do
something like that certainly so we can
start to look at those numbers for you
um that have been reported on the
returns and have that ready for
um for your work session thank you uh
represent ames
no i'm sorry if my hand is still up it
shouldn't be
okay represented thank you mr chairman
on
i i had a question about how
uh water's edge fits into this
when uh subsidiaries and and
on subcontractors are
on are applying for ppp that cannot be
applied for
by the larger corporation
and um i did find it in the lebanon
results
a neighbor who um is a
on
is a um i'm not sure what the legal
relationship
is but works within a
corporation in vermont that uh does
drainage work
uh and who uh applied for ppp on his own
in new hampshire um
[Music]
so i'm not i'm not really sure how
all of these things fit together but
whether
on would it make a difference
or does your 47 account for that really
if on there are a large number of
small ppp applicants that received loans
that became grants
or will become grants um and
on they are incorporated into filings
under water edge order's edge from the
large taxpayers
sure so the the simplest way i think to
answer that question
is how they file for new hampshire tax
purposes as a consolidated return
potentially
under as a water's edge corporation
that may not be the same as how they
filed for ppp
their their two separate statutory
requirements
and so again how they file in new
hampshire
may not be the same how they lawfully
file or correctly file in new hampshire
may not have been how they filed for ppp
but that doesn't mean that how they
filed for ppp was wrong
the the requirements for how the number
of employees were determined in the
various
other requirements in order to be
eligible for ppp
may have allowed for subsidiaries of who
we view to be a large multinational
waters edge corporation
they may have qualified under ppp
under the law as drafted so they're
almost apples and oranges
um the 47 that's a good question
that is based on our filings so that
assumes
the water's edge consolidated return
filing so again there may be a
discrepancy there between
how they file and how they may have been
eligible for ppp
and and i had on a request also
that on main
when we were asked to do the same thing
for the main street program i was told
yet yesterday uh by
uh miss layer about on
uh how much that that is on your records
and i'd like that to be given to the
committee
sure we can certainly provide that so
you you do mention a good point
um grants under main street and south
and any of the other state
programs using cares act funds um
[Music]
do not have the same additional benefit
afforded to them at the federal level
and then obviously not at the state
level
so a main street grant for instance a
building
business that received the full the
maximum main street amount of 350
000 that grant is included in taxable
and gross income excuse me at the
federal level and the expenses can be
deducted
which is the same as how we treat them
at the state level as well
but we'll get you the analysis assuming
that sb3
also applied to the main street itself
brands
right and that would be true
as long as congress doesn't say it
doesn't change the rules and make these
other things very
act that is correct under
current law as of today right
representative spellsbury
yes thank you mr chairman um you
mentioned uh earlier lindsay that
naturally this affects all businesses
subject
to our business tax regardless of
whether they're domiciled in
new hampshire so do we have any sense
of how that breaks out proportionally
how much of
this would effectively benefit
non-new hampshire businesses
not specifically because again i can't
tie the data to our individual records
so without the identification numbers i
can't look to a specific business's
apportionment
to know how exactly
they would in it would impact new
hampshire businesses
i suppose that's probably the answer you
were going to give but
in light of that is it probable that
it's a significant percentage
i would say as a whole the majority of
our revenues
obviously come from businesses that are
not domiciled here in new hampshire
you know we have one state and one
business
one state's worth of businesses and we
have 50 states worth of businesses that
could be
conducting business here um
where that analysis gets tricky is when
you start to consider
as representative omni was alluded
alluding to obviously the largest
portion of our revenues
come from large multinational
organizations that are unlikely to
have been able to get ppp
and so when you start taking those out
of the equation
i don't have a good handle on how that
likely
impacts the new hampshire portion of
businesses to the total portion of
businesses
obviously it starts to dilute it um and
again just based on
the 0.4 percent apportionment that we
typically use
and again that's based on population um
i would say that
the majority of businesses that would
benefit from this
um would be businesses that are not
domiciled in new hampshire
but obviously businesses that are
dominant styled in new hampshire would
benefit from this as well
a quick follow-up if i may follow up
yeah purely hypothetical so i i only
want to sort of refer to this
but if we were in the single sales
factor stage already
that would make it even more complicated
and undeterminable wouldn't it
it would most likely because um
sales well one we would have to be a
couple years in or at least a full year
into single sales factors so that we
would have that data off of our returns
um and then also one of the things with
single sales factor is it is the most
volatile factor when it comes to
apportionment
obviously your sales in any given state
can change pretty easily from year to
year
a good marketing campaign in texas could
really you know drive up your sales in
texas
where property and payroll are factors
that tend to be more stable over time
um so yes if we were in single sales
especially during a pandemic the data
would be
a little more volatile and would make
our analysis potentially more difficult
you're confirming exactly what i
suspected
uh further questions of lindsay do you
have anything else to add lindsey
i do not we will get you the follow-up
information which i have in my notes as
the bulleted overview of the difference
between the state and federal treatment
that i went over at the beginning
we will put the full amount of potential
ppp to be
issued through our analysis to give you
an updated fiscal note taking that into
account
we will start to analyze the numbers
that we've received on the schedule
4 for returns we've received to date
that report ppp amounts
and we'll also calculate the impact if
senate bill 3
was expanded to include the
state level main street and south
programs
okay thank you
any further questions from the committee
and then thank you again lindsay
very much nice to see everyone
is there anybody else janine
no there's not um
no all right does anybody else wish to
comment or have questions or contribute
to the public hearing on senate bill 3.
if not i'm going to close the public
hearing on senate bill 3
and i would anticipate we would be
having at least a couple of work
sessions
on senate bill 3. and i
i would also encourage
the members to throw
the information that they have
especially the information
that have been provided on the
other states now what percentage of
their revenues come from
say income tax sales tax
corporate tax and all that because
when you start making decisions on what
other states do
you gotta analyze
how is that going to affect new
hampshire new hampshire
is different than all the other states
new hampshire is the only state
without a broad-based sales tax and a
broad-based
income tax therefore new hampshire
cannot recover
any additional funds due to ppp loans
these other states with an income tax
and sales tax
if they do not tax
the ppp loans still get the benefit
of the tax on wages
and the sales tax on goods and services
so you've got to remember all these
things they all tie together
so anybody else have anything else they
want to contribute
if not um we will
go right our next bill which i think
will be very short
and our last bill
which is senate bill 112.
i would take a break but i don't think
this is going to last
oh wow wait a minute um
but it's only fair to ask you do you
want to take a break and come back in 30
minutes
or do you want to plow through this no i
don't want to take a second
plow through follow through okay
thank you
this is a public hearing on senate bill
112 and act
relative to historic racing and
we did a side-by-side comparison on this
bill compared to senate bill
uh 2 626 and then
there's essentially no difference except
a few
minor word changes which
doesn't change the intent of the bill
so essentially senate bill 12 appears
senate bill 12 is the same thing as
as house bill 626 which passed our
committee in the senate last week five
to
five to zero and it's going to be on the
consent calendar
in the senate we have
signed up for that three people
uh and they're all in support uh
i'm sorry the first is opposing
do we have um
in place of senator french we have uh
representative grant bossie
and representative bossie you're going
to
introduce the bill for senator french
yes
your indulgence mr chairman
go ahead representative boston
thank you not a representative good
afternoon
mr chairman and members of the committee
my name is grant bosse i'm the majority
policy director
for the new hampshire senate here today
on behalf of senator french the prime
sponsor of senate bill 112 he is not
available
and asked me to introduce the bill he
thanks you for your courtesy
uh senate bill 112 would establish
paramutual pools for historic house
racing the senate approved it with a
strong vote of 20-4
and as the chairman said the issue is
quite familiar to you
having approved a nearly identical bill
house bill
626 just last month that bill is
scheduled to be heard by the full senate
on thursday so it could be on its way to
the governor
before you get around to this bill
historic racing pools would provide
another
option for the licensed game operators
currently working in new hampshire
and would generate an estimated 12.2
million dollars
annually for the education trust fund as
well as six million dollars a year for
local charities
i defer on the subject matter experts on
the details of the bill senator french
thanks you for your consideration
and ask for your support for senate bill
112. thank you very much
and do you take questions uh i could um
but i'd likely have to
take down the question and take it to
senator french and he'd give an answer
back to you
thank you mr bosses um
the next if i take him in order of the
sign up
is a michael remy from keene new
hampshire an elected official
opposing representative
remy is representative remy
i just let him in okay
hello i'm uh mr chair thank you uh
all for having me i'm actually a city
councilor in the city of keene
um i'm not particularly opposed or
in favor of the language itself for the
bill i think that this
i mean it's up to the group as far as uh
what the the right decision is here but
what i am a little bit
uh disappointed in is that the current
date that's chosen
excludes one uh license holder
and that one license holder happens to
be in the city of keene
and i find that that's a little bit
disappointing that
there was a floor amendment to this bill
that was proposed
by senator khan that was uh
was declined that would adjust the date
to december 31st
of 2020 instead of may um and that would
have included this last license holder
who
opened the business during kovid and now
we're excluding them for some reason
from being able to participate in this
uh
this opportunity so while i'm not a
speaking in favor or opposed to the bill
itself i do find it disappointing that
we would exclude one person from this
and i said the same thing before the
senate when they were reviewing 626.
well thank you for your testimony to
take questions
if i i'm not sure what i can answer but
i would happy to take any questions
[Music]
representing early
followed by representative schamberg
repleni
representing earlier yeah after trying
to find it
sleeping turn off button uh if this
is uh this is a question of the chair
sir
if this bill is identical to the other
bill would it not be appropriate for us
at this time
to do essentially nothing because
the other bill is already
past the senate that is up to the
committee
representative
thank you mr schoenberg uh i guess this
is a question for
someone that wrote bill 626
was kane excluded in that bill also
um
romney do you want to respond to that uh
yeah so in
in both uh six to six and
oh sorry go ahead and explain that
representative
sorry uh sorry uh in both 626 and uh
and 112 they were both um
they were both set to that may date i'm
not sure what the significance of that
date was but it is excluded in both so
unfortunately that 66 has already passed
this committee
thank you
okay any further questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
the next
is michael appleberg
from nashville new hampshire a member of
the public
uh representing the united way of
greater nashua and support
i do not see this person here
okay the next is
well it's not going to be here either
right there no
and there's nobody else speaking
there's a total of 47 in support of the
bill
three opposed
anybody else wish to spake on this bill
so i did i would uh representative
tucker if there's
i gather that the fact that it's past um
both houses means we don't have to
really consider this i would certainly
go along with that
you said it was up to the committee
perhaps you could pose the question
you know how to word it correctly i'm
going to let the
public hearing continue until the end oh
i see
i didn't realize it was in conflict
sorry
and then when we go into an executive
session which is not today
we can handle that ah i see okay thank
you
representative romney this is going to
have to be testimony because
i'm a co-sponsor on uh senate bill 112
as well so
so representative rami uh rockham 19.
so uh i did have conversation
with both uh senator guida as well as
senator french
and uh they're all in agreement that
that
that senator house bill 626 be the
vehicle
and that they have no problem that uh if
we retain this or whatever we decide to
do
uh because the other bill is is already
on the way
uh i think it's on consent calendar in
the senate
so um so it's
all but i think passed so
um i see uh grant
grant has his hand up i could i could
address that it is on the consent
calendar there were two floor amendments
one to change the date and address that
keen operator that was defeated on the
senate floor
the first time and on this bill
and the second was a local option
essentially allowing the municipality to
decide whether
these would be allowed that was also
defeated by the full senate
um it is on the consent calendar it may
be taken off the consent calendar but it
got a 20-4 vote i would anticipate
passage and heading into the governor's
desk
that would leave you in possession of a
senate bill um
that you could you know work your way on
thank you for responding bossy
uh anything else representative romney
no
i i think we are the senate in the
senate ways of means and house
leadership anyway is is a
kind of agreement as to what should
happen next and we can talk about that
when we we bring up the bill for uh vote
all right um since we won't be
going in executive session anybody else
wish to speak
in favor or in opposition to senate bill
112. i don't see any hands raised
so i'm going to close the public hearing
on senate bill 112.
that ends our public hearing today i
want to remind
everybody that tomorrow is going to be
meeting
with the lba and the dra
talk revenues
and that will start tomorrow at
the right time kind of car
anybody else any further business
if not we are adjourned
and thank you for hanging in there today